three two hello people of the internet I
never did classic that's me hello Ela
welcome to H3 after dark nice to have
you it's uh December 8th my my how the
time Rolls by doesn't it mhm I'm so Star
Struck to be on my favorite podcast yeah
I mean I listen all week and then I get
to be on it that's
nice you know I
am available to you for more uh purposes
than that I know you're pretty busy well
I make time for my
fans I always make time for my fans you
know I love my fans anyway guys welcome
to hear uh we actually have sponsors
today so let's give it up let's go the
hexclad and Gamer sucks who we love we
love them they us fed and and drink one
Keeps Us fed yeah yeah all the the
pillars of Life yeah um we have a fun
show of course as usual when do we ever
disappoint other
than this entire
week but that's also sorry yeah that's
the cricket's moment I'm just being a
little sensitive cuz people have been
mad at me for uh for some stuff I did
this week
anyway uh we have um you need to leave
they live forever guys calling into the
show at two Brian Johnson That's so
exciting actually I'm I'm both like I
had no idea that was happening until
today I I have I there is a genuine
curiosity mhm on surface level it's like
this dude's weird but like
there's also I think some legitimate
scientific Pursuit going on there yeah
you know it's complicated yeah it's
complic he's a complic but I'll tell you
what else is Weird Brian Johnson you
know who else is named to Brian Johnson
lver King yes yeah I was watching and
have we are we trying to get them in the
same room have we had any progress on
that no no no progress on that have we
reached out to Li that would be great
and I mean they would have so much to
talk about cuz you know Bri the rich
Brian John would be like well they're
both Rich that's true I think this one
we're talking to is probably richer
though Mega Rich yeah he's like Mega
rich rich briyan will tell Rich briyan
he's got the science he's like bro
you're nuts yeah and then like
here bite into these raw
testicles um so he's going to call in
I'm looking forward to that also big
announcement guys the live show is
coming next weekend and the polling is
up guys go on Twitter is this tweet
pinned love it's already next weekend no
it's not but I'll pin it right now yeah
so the Tweet will be pinned call them
dumps the Voting is
open for the streamy 2020 steamies 2023
Excuse excuse
me and uh boy we got some great nominees
some great categories and we're all so
so excited this sun or no next Sunday I
mean MH is our
ultimate uh final show of the
Year night it's YouTube's hottest night
baby yes that's that's what everyone
says about it how is it already December
it's crazy it's
nuts actually ela's birthday's next week
too yeah
wow so you'll be
306 no you're
36 will be oh all right that makes sense
yeah what' you think 36 I thought 37 for
some reason lucky I wish I was you could
convince me I'm honestly not 100% cuz
I'm 38 so you would be turning 36 yeah
that makes
sense yeah you're young I you know what
I mean I like them
young I feel like where C that I can't
should I button that it's a no I would
clip that like no you're going never
know anym I feel so old but I don't know
I'm I know that it's young too they say
50s is the new 20s but you know who says
that people
70s well and Brian Johnson the man we're
about to speak with yeah Brian Johnson
apparently says he's 25 I don't buy it
though I've seen his
face I mean I don't I don't buy it he's
not he I mean he looks like he's 40 well
you can tell that to his face 20 minutes
will if that is your real face Brian how
old is he
uh he is 46 I believe Immortal okay he's
looking pretty good for 46 yeah I think
he looks incredible for 46 I didn't
realize his body is nuts he's like
jacked yeah he's really jacked so I
guess we should get right into it
because he's going to call in 20 minutes
and he seems like the kind of guy who's
like I'm here it's 2:00 I have 20
minutes to give you and then I'm leaving
did he give us a heart out he did not he
didn't actually yeah and he he expressed
excit
so I'm so excited I feel like you guys
are not excited enough about that I am
I'm excited he is an interesting guy
Team rocks they seem and I'll say this
he seems like a good sport too yeah like
he seems like he's a nice guy and a good
sport about everything so I I think
we'll have a fun combo with him actually
one before we get into that which we we
should get on it pretty quickly here I
want had one other thing I want to say
about the live show just a reminder for
those in attendance there will not be a
dress code
enforced but Formal Wear is highly
encouraged it's the spirit of the night
it's the hottest night it's YouTube's
sexiest night you don't want to be
coming not looking sexy looking like a
schub that being said also my mom was
asking me what to wear and I was like
just anything so should I okay I was
going to say also I also want to
emphasize next to that that this is all
super expensive and also don't feel you
really don't need to feel yeah like I
said that not in Forest won't look on
you if you don't feel like not be judged
not be judged but it's just it's it's
more like dressing up in a costume than
actually uh it's for fun if you have a
nice outfit at home you know what I mean
then put that on we'll we'll all be in
tuxes and stuff uh up on stage and so if
you want to get into the spirit of the
night that's the way to do it let's not
talk about making money I know my mom is
planning on wearing Teddy fresh she
already told me she's like I'm just
going to wear my teddy first is she
going to be in is she the crowd yeah
okay is you can be backstage you need to
be in the crowd oh gotcha I don't know I
don't know well we'll figure it out I
don't know not think about nobody
regardless um the polling is up how many
votes do we have in so far Ian it's we
we've got quite a bit
already but yes go over to go over to
Twitter it's pinned it should also be in
the comments probably as well and um we
have uh 30,000 votes wow all right we
are not starting the show until there's
100,000 and we need a million likes also
so start smashing that like button right
now 30,000 that's a lot 30,000 that is a
lot how many do we have last year do do
we have uh access to the historical
record last year looks like
107,000 whoa okay but I don't think we
did the big push I think we only pushed
this at the end of stavos of stavros's
yeah it was kind of a soft launch to be
honest this is a much harder launch
today so yeah get your votes
in oh here's an interesting comment
a few my co-workers never heard of Teddy
fresh until the collab with MTG but knew
about the a podcast lo I couldn't stop
raving about TF yeah dude love you
love your that's exactly what I was
hoping that would
happen that actually makes me so happy I
think I have
um bronchitis or something I think I
might need to see the doctor cuz like
great I can't stop is that is that um
contagious yes well I don't have a fever
or feel bad in any way I just have this
cough that's not getting it's not
improving and it's very flemy and it I
think that happened feels bad I mean you
were sick recently right because I'm
kind of having that right now too to be
honest I sick this last week was the
same with our boys Tor had a cough
forever after he was sick oh somebody
says will there be a TF sale at the live
show you know there will be there will
be fans be ready because we are doing
our our usual Sample Sales insanely
marked down and frankly all the best
items a lot of them are sold out a lot
of them are favorites there's going to
be a huge variety of stuff and they're
all going to be Mega markdown for our
fans it's a fan service we love them let
the conversation begin this this venue
is massive so I understand the the merch
Booth will be bigger and more uh
accommodating yes and there's going to
be uh significantly more line management
going on than there was at the live show
if people were in attendance and
remember what a mess it was out the
lobby cuz there was a million people
getting in line and it was just kind of
a free-for-all uh so we're on top of
that this time a lot more organized this
time yeah we're on top of it bronchitis
itself isn't contagious but some of its
causes are okay yeah that's what I
thought it's just when you have in
your lungs if your bronchitis is caused
by a virus you can be contagious for a
few days to a week what are the symptoms
of bronchitis let's see if I have
that they are it's just kind of a
buzzword you know why don't you ask our
guest when he calls he seems like the
typ guy he's not a doctor but probably
one sitting next to him he probably
doesn't get sick ever right that's a
good question for him that is a good
question runny stuffy nose low grade
fever I don't have a fever chest
congestion you don't have a stuffy nose
either wheezing no my nose is clear
isn't that weird it's not weird it's
just the stuff is lingering it's exactly
what but it's been a week and of no
improvement
no weaseling wheezing or whistling while
breathing no cough that may produce
yellow or green mucus I am producing
green mucus feeling run down and tired
that's so
me that's so me um also besides Brian
Johnson calling in we have huge breaking
Selena Gomez drama um it is hot it is
fresh everybody's buzzing about this
Selena Gomez drama and Olivia is going
to take our hand and lead us to the
promised land of Selena Gomez T mhm just
got engaged and he's the one who showed
me age3 let's go let's go Cheryl let's
go husband Cheryl
beer is that that last name about to
change
beer excuse me well her last name is
beer she says she's getting married or
she already married let's see I mean
don't you know that women can keep their
own last name Ethan well with a name
like beer I thought that maybe I'm kid
there's nothing wrong with beer what's
wrong with beer nothing beer I feel like
you get I don't know if you were like
wanted to bully someone you could like
beer yeah she's like five what's up
beer you could say anybody's name like
that why you annoying beer like a bee in
my
ear well if she wasn't changing her name
before now she is beer somebody said uh
might be pneumonia that's a good guess
let's see
great that might be what I was thinking
of maybe lupus cough which may produce
green fever sweating sh shaking chills
no shortness of breath no rapid shallow
breathing no sharper stabbing chest pain
no loss of appetite low energy fatigue
yes oh there it is you got it except
lost of appetite
that's that's when I'm really up
when I'm don't feel like eating that's
when life is really I need to see a
doctor at that point
you know
right but anyway people are saying uh
they could bully you for Klein in the
exact same way in the chat kleene what's
up kleene the clown how do you know that
that's what they sound like because they
they stretched out all the vowels
Klein okay whatever swer love woo swer
I'm going to Swerve into uncoming
traffic yeah I'm going to I'm going to
go I'm going to do a double homicide
murder into this oncoming traffic epic
swer of
Love yeah it's a little that's a little
that's Innovative I mean I did get yeah
I got some bullying for my last name
when I was a kid but uh no oncoming
traffic jokes there you go yeah doing
it what kind of bowling did you get uh
gez what would they say uh you know
frankly there were always really dumb I
mean I'm talking like elementary school
and in the 90s too not that it's
different now not uh I don't know but s
swer gay cuz love the love that
is I'm telling you it's bad s gay and I
told them it was bad at the time but
bullies don't really uh they don't care
for feedback gay that's crazy you sound
kind of lame saying that to me just
saying yeah is that what you said yeah
exactly that bully them right back were
you like ew homophobia is never okay
yeah was
and you were right no I'm just sign that
you're gay I didn't know that I didn't
read
it what when am I going to get a hold of
Jesse ibody said uh Dan turd love that
would have been way better I never that
wasn't one that I ever got turd love the
poop eater my bullies weren't they
weren't the smartest what can I say yeah
morons where are they now
probably crying single lonely destitute
idiot morons losers dumb ass absolutely
probably passed out in their own
and filth wondering they're
thinking about
Dan and how well Dan God I hope so oh
God I hope so I hope that my Bullies Are
you know being burned okay alive in
their minds right mentally in Minecraft
right I hope they're being burned alive
in Minecraft burning the witch falling
in lava and losing all their diamond
armor idiot dumb asses morons brutal I
didn't wish that that's
crazy all right so um let's see here we
should get up to um up to speed on bri
yeah let's get up to speed on bri yeah
Bri BR so Brian Johnson you guys have
probably seen I've been talking about
him for a while off and on he's a
fascinating character and I've seen a
lot of people on the internet discussing
him um he's
46 he claims multiple parts of his body
have the biological age of 18 he has a
team of 30 doctors and spends $2 million
a year trying to reverse the effects of
Aging he uh built a mobile payment
startup called brain tree which also
owned venmo the company was purchased by
PayPal in eight uh for $800 million in
2013 he said that during that period in
his life he was chronically depressed
and would binge eat so he's a ultra
wealthy and I guess retire or not he's
not working in the tradition was he not
always super fit no actually actually
interestingly I saw the pictures of him
when he was like in Tech and all that he
looks completely different and a little
overweight too which is not which is
really something I I do we have a pick
of him from
before there's a link a little lower in
that right up uh which number number
eight thank you yeah here he is before
um God he looks so different you guys
you're not even going to recognize
him go Bri
BR my name is Pat Ryan welcome to
Chicago founder stories here at 1871
Chicago's new digital startup Hub third
stories we sold out once again and weing
it for people able to get tonight if you
haven't seen the first
did he actually looks like
younger that's him that is him he's just
some dork I mean and I me that with
peace and love of course he doesn't look
overweight or anything but just
normal average build you
know fa.com Uber and we powered our
credit card payments isn't that crazy I
think that's a totally different so what
year is this from cuz cuz he looks the
same age or potentially even younger I
would I might even say although well it
was posted six years ago um I don't know
if this was when it was recorded what
year is probably then it's probably six
years ago yeah probably
okay so that's pretty interesting right
yeah um Bri BR
is um currently he takes 111 supplements
a day he stops eating at 11 a.m. no he
does like hardcore intermittent fasting
okay stops eating at 11:00 a.m. he eats
exact exactly
2,250 calories every day at what
hour he this is this dude probably wakes
up at like 400 a.m. kind of oh my
God you know he says every calorie has
to fight for its life there's not a
single calorie in my entire life
protocol that exists for any reason
other than serving an objective in the
body wow he calls this whole regiment
and uh
scientific uh Journey project
blueprint here's a super cut of his
morning routine we need to send him
and's chocolate and see I don't think
he'd eat it I think he's like he's so
hardcore like I I almost feel
like it well let here I'll I measure my
inner ear temperature every day I do
this as a safety and efficacy check for
various therapies we're doing if I'm
running hot then we know it's an
indicator of something so temp this
morning was 96 so my body runs around uh
3 3° F roughly cooler than normal most
people are 98.7 thereabouts I run around
955 or 96 it's a result of my dietary
protocol I'll flip on this UV light this
is 10,000 Lux at 12 in I turn this on
and I usually just enjoy thinking about
the day for a minute I just get a few
minutes of exposure it helps set
circadian rhythm it improves sleep going
to do 5 minutes of light therapy like
this sh that to me seems goofy like
light sending in front of a light but I
don't know the man's he's he's pretty
serious with the science somebody threw
out there recently that they liked the
light therapy I know on the crew people
like Chiropractic I feel like I've heard
about that in New York maybe where it's
like super depressing and you don't get
enough sunlight is is like facial
gadgets he lives in California use yeah
the mask
wasn't there somebody telling us that
they they do that and they like it can
can you look up ab is that red light
mask and all this light therapy actually
a thing I mean he looks so good I it has
to well it's not just this right you
know but it's something magic is
happening light and it keeps my
complexion clear 5 minutes and it's also
a nice time to do a little meditation
I'll focus on my breathing always W up
naturally so it's somewhere with neon
light Jes Christ man what happened I
thought you were just he he's a lamp
he's a human lamp
seriously I'll focus on my breathing I
always wake up naturally so it's
somewhere between 4:30 and 6:00 a.m. I
wake up I go to bed at the same time
every single night we're trying to
basically I think he goes to bed at like
some crazy ass like 8:00 p.m. type of
but like does he have fun
ever if you were to ask me looking at
this from the outside I it looks to me
like his life is miserable but he seems
to be enjoying what he's doing I don't
think he has a normal type of
Personality MH I think he he there's
something going on that's unusual about
this man there has to be you know sure
every single organ of the entire body
and we're trying to rejuvenate the age
and so every day when my team and I meet
up we're talking about like you know the
heart the lungs or the pancreas the
liver and so sometimes the analysis is
we look at the data we've acquired we do
some sort of assessment on the therapy
and then we implement it but my job is
to basically go through this full
process from identifying the organ to do
looking at the analysis and then
incorporating it so sometimes that's
taking a pill sometimes it's putting a
new device sometimes it's you know a new
exercise protocol sometimes it's a new
meditation practice I now think of
myself as a professional Rejuvenation
athlete my life is trying to be be the
science it's it's like being the entire
process of the discovery and Analysis to
the implementation I understand that
he's just doing it on
himself and not like risking somebody
else true for his own benefit you know I
agree I mean well yeah I don't I don't
think it would be ethical to do it to
somebody else uh necessarily although I
guess you could do it as part of a
clinical trial but I think it's I agree
I mean you know he's living it and he's
taking it seriously yeah he's he's Dr
Frankenstein in the sense that
it's his own creation yeah and the old
bran that we saw is inside him screaming
for help for
release let me out in the dark place or
whatever people look at this they're
like that's nuts it is nuts but it's
exactly what's required in the year 2023
if you want to do this entire process
trying to look at every organ in the
body this is the device I use for my dry
eye I'll do this for 30 seconds in the
morning when I wake up and the first
time you would do this it's going to be
the most intense like an orgasmic sneeze
every two weeks my team organizes all
the pills again yeah he does that for
dry eyes what's an orgasmic sneeze well
I I I know what he means about a
satisfying sneeze yeah but but like what
the is that have to do with dry
eyes dude you're rubbing your nostril
brother my dry eye I'll do if it makes
you sneeze does it make your eyes water
30 seconds in the morning when I wake up
and the first time you would do this
might be something to that I guess I'm
not I'm not even doubting I'm just
saying this guy he's he's got he's on
another level like he's rubbing his nose
keep his eyes wet you know who's doing
that who else is doing that when you get
like punched in the nose your eyes get
super watery so maybe MH it's
alled um first of all I wonder if he
even watches television if he does I
wonder if he watch that documentary that
we just watched about the C uh love has
won and the the Love Has one cult and
the leader the mother God she was
drinking colloidal silver so I'm curious
what's his take about colloidal
silver that was a long way to say that
right what's the research on colloidal
silver there uh AB by the way red light
therapy shows premise in various areas
but scientific evidence is not
conclusive for all of its purported
benefits more research is need to fully
understand its Effectiveness and the
best way to use it addition thanks te
additionally results May uh vary from
person to person benefits include skin
health pain relief
inflammation pain and inflammation
relief Muscle Recovery hair growth mood
and sleep I what the doesn't it do
I get I get skeptical when it's like you
know there's too much good things going
on sneezing and orgasms both produce
endorphins which make your body feel
good oh okay so there's an orgasmic
sneeze there you go there's like yeah
some kind of myth about about it
creating a mini orgasm but not true it's
not even close to the number nobody
believes that yeah right I mean is
enough there be a few articles about it
I've heard that before it just like an
analogy yeah I think so maybe when I was
a kid I mean you just you don't sneeze
and cream your pants at least I have't
yeah um about the red light thing we
should ask him what he thinks about
getting a red light on your taint like
Tucker Carlson was pitching last year
remember thatan if it's good for the
face it's good for the tank but yeah
that's a good question as well you know
a lot of people surprisingly drink that
colloidal silver thing so what is
colloidal silver somebody at Teddy fresh
yesterday had a drink with colloidal
silver wait no no no no no yeah oh youc
that doesn't that turn people blue yeah
yeah I know I'm Prett sure that's like a
total this woman by the way picture she
slowly dying throughout the documentary
mostly from liver failure but she turns
blue like her she becomes like dark blue
like a Smurf and she drinks it like
medicine every day the colloidal silver
because they also sell it so she kind of
like what wait we should we should talk
about it offline who that is we might
need to do an intervention I I'm pretty
sure that that is like totally bogus and
actually like kind of dangerous to do
well is it dangerous as soon as I saw it
I was like don't drink that you're going
to turn oh my God it says clal silver it
sounds like a hemopathy thing clal
silver has been used for infections hay
skin conditions many others but there's
no good scientific evidence to support
any of its uses uh colloidal silver
consists of tiny silver particles and
liquid is sometimes promoted on the
internet as a dietary supplement is it
dangerous uh well I'm seeing uh on a
government website the US Food and Drug
Administration has warned that collidal
silver isn't safe or effective for
treating any disease or condition I
wouldn't think so I mean it's just
ground up silver what's that going to do
for me it's not even like an essential
mineral yeah I'm seeing the chat is
pretty much all in agreement that it's
not so a good idea there's someone
drinking a fancy drink with yeah silver
sand in it yeah it looked all like you
know fancy and
expensive it calls kidney damage and
seizures oh my God yeah no those are the
risks
yeah this doesn't sound too bad well
also I could interact with other
medications and also it turns you blue
like
why are people want to do that do you
want to share a picture I want to look
up colloidal colloidal silver blue skin
let's just see what we find here oh uh
just so you know Brian has entered the
waiting room no shot is this guy
real oh yeah look at this yeah yeah that
that's that's very famous uh what how
silver you drinking there bro yeah oh my
god brother you're
blue are you kidding me brother
wow you're blue boy what what' you do to
your damn skin boy you walk around all
blue I a never seen myself of no blue
man before why are you still drinking it
then I don't like
that it's kind of a Vibe it's a good
vibe
I so different terrible Vibes um Bro
Look at that he's happy about it too he
likes it all right so Brian is here
Brian is here um 's one minute left I'll
just finish this Brian if you're
watching just to uh set you up properly
here mhm it's going to be the most
intense it's like an orgasmic sneeze
every 2 weeks my team organizes all the
pills in between that time duration we
change certain things and when we change
it it's a manual change and these manual
pills become my responsibility I don't
know how many pills in here I think last
time we reported it was something like
over 50 maybe
[Music]
60 I'll use red light therapy I started
losing my hair ears has been a difficult
thing I've had to work really hard to
try to keep ahead of hair and this is a
useful thing it's one of uh six
different things I do this is what I'm
going to eat after we work out I rotate
every month one month puree one month
bro what's on your head it's the red
light dude I know but like you're just
walking around he saying the red light
helps with his hair loss that's what he
says he's working on it I got to
get on that yeah same bro just get plug
I mean I would tell him just get plugs I
mean
you're the well I wonder cuz he said he
started losing his hair at a very young
age I wonder if he 30 think he already
did oh that could be well I don't know
and he might not even be in denying that
he he might fess up to
that whole pieces yeah overall it's it's
a lot of vegetables every month it's
over 50 lb I think that it's a slop
walket yeah what was in that I don't
know what it was Ray goo so anyway
there's a little overview about what
he's up to and uh let's get him on the
the phone man okay stand by I'll set him
up here but there's ALS there's a lot of
other stuff I want to show you guys and
I'll show those I guess uh with him to
comment on them
MH all right I am uh bringing him into
the room right now just one
moment uh Brian are you there hey what's
up hello there he is tech tech
trillionaire Brian
Johnson Brian are you aware that do you
know who liver King
is I think think he's the Brian Johnson
in a parallel universe that's
right and so if I'm trying would you
would you get in maybe like a same I
want to get you guys in a conversation
the war of the Brian Brian uh Johnson's
would you have a conversation with liver
do we communicate with grunts or
language well you do you and he'll do
him okay just want to make sure we could
yes happy too it is pretty interesting
though how you guys are like so
different like I literally ying-yang
anyway how are you thanks for calling in
thanks for having me so you uh let's see
here are you currently treating anything
in your body right now like do you have
your feet in a red light or anything
like
that uh let me think about
it nothing currently right now that's
surprising you're you're you're missing
out on Prime uh opportunity here so tell
me about um when you got started on this
journey of uh project blueprint to slow
or stop
aging yeah i' love this this thought
experiment I read a lot of biographies
and I love reading about the past and
seeing people in their time and place
who did epic things and I know most of
us are concerned about what goes on here
and now but the 25th Century is going to
have a perspective of us right now and
99.9% of what we do is going to be wiped
away to history and I thought what would
be the coolest thing to do from the the
perspective of the 25th Century like
what is a thing that we figure out in
the early 21st century and that's what
blo is is like basically I observe that
we've achieved a level of intelligence
uh with AI in spe specifically that we
don't know any longer how long and how
well we can live the death used to be
inevitable maybe it's not anymore and so
that's what this is about it's about a
zi shift that the 21st century would say
oh yeah that's obvious but we look at it
we think it's nuts that doesn't make any
sense at all so are you is there a
chance that you don't
die
yeah if you to put this into perspective
imagine we're hanging out a million
years ago with Homo erectus and they
have an axe in their hand and we're like
hey homerus what's up how's it going
they hadn't innovated in the act for a
million years and you're like hey can
you riff for us tell us what the future
of the species is like you know we would
just view homoerectus from a form of
entertainment we wouldn't think they'd
be spitting lyrics about quantum
mechanics or about SpaceTime or about
the internet or being able to call
someone anywhere in the world at any
moment uh and the same thing I wonder if
we are basically the equivalent of Homo
rectus right now if that whatever we say
about the future has no bearing
whatsoever because we're going to move
at the speed of 100 Year a million years
of revolutionary advance in a very short
period of time and you look at how fast
artificial intelligence is moving so yes
like basically I think uh we can say
nothing about the future in this moment
we are basically homoerectus Brian I
feel that you're dodging the question
will you
die uh okay by a percentage what chance
are we looking at here of Brian dying
one day
the fact that you're even thinking about
this is interesting true yeah yeah so
you're saying there's a chance you just
keep going you keep living on yeah
Brian Johnson
Forever
uh we have all of the technical tools to
solve aging and we just need a bit more
time to solve the problem it's it does
solving aging does not break the laws of
physics
well there are some animals that don't a
they could I think theoretically live
forever right there's some ocean
creatures uh Jellyfish I think I I
forget which ones but there are some
quote unquote immortal animals in nature
exactly yeah yeah that's right we have
biology has proven that it is possible
to live a very long time what are the
animals that are Immortal do you do you
recall I'm curious I think it was a uh
Hydra Greek Shar Red Sea Urchin clams a
shark a Greenland shark Greenland shark
lives forever lobsters lobsters really
holy the ocean what's going on in
the ocean Brian they've There's
Something In The Water literally I'm
missing out I should be I should set up
shop down there you you should be
drinking uh ocean water I should try to
grow some gills
and yeah so um are you afraid of dying
yeah Brian you know
you're running from it yeah you know
what you're also doing science but
personally you you're also invested in
this do you think about
dying I wonder if it would make people
feel better if I was scared of dying I I
wonder is that question really about me
or is it about the person asking the
question wow no it's about you I mean
just for the record you're the one that
hold on you're the guy that dedicates
his whole life to not dying and
literally just refus to answer the
question will you die so I really don't
think that it's a self accusing question
I do Wonder though of how much people do
say about me is self- commentary or
really is about me like
what I mean take your thing there's so
many things to choose
from so there it's true that you do get
a lot of flak online um I think mostly
because it's just it's just odd frankly
uh on the surface level it's just a
little bit like
wow this is this is pretty weird and
wild but you know like the question is
is it odd according to 2023 standards or
is it odd to 2030 standards or to 2040
the thing that's odd is like nobody
wants to be left behind in the future
and so the question is is this really
the future because if you're identifying
that okay I'm not doing something that
is considered quote unquote normal in
2023 but is this going to be normal in
2030 if it is you want in it's the
future we none of us want to be in the
past and that's what I think is the
legitimate question here is is people
use the word weird as some Shortcut to
try to exclude somebody from our social
tribe like hey they don't belong with us
because we here are normal people humans
that person's weird therefore they don't
belong as part of us but what's the
origin and what's the justification for
making that observation so you ref you
are refuting the weird claims It's a
lazy form of assessment you know it's
just like you look through history like
what isn't Weir it's a snap judgment
though you know what I mean but but here
I'll ask you this I mean if we're
talking about uh making these kinds of
increased lifespans
accessible how are people who don't have
$2
million per year to spend on medical uh
going to benefit from your
research yeah everything I've done is
freely shared with the entire world all
my data all my protocols all my recipes
every pill I take everything is shared
for free with everyone and you can
someone can do blueprint in the US for
between $1,000 and $1,500 per month
which includes groceries so it's
absolutely affordable for most people
people can go to bed on time and doesn't
cost them anything and so these things
people hear the $2 million tag and they
think oh no that's totally inacessible
and I can't do anything the majority of
the power laws for longevity are in the
most basic things it's in exercise sleep
and diet the basics we all know so no
it's absolutely not true that this is
outside the reach of almost anyone and
even if you don't have money to buy you
know a high quality food you can still
go to bed on time and exercise where did
that 2 million number come
from it's the money I've spent we went
through a process and we said um okay so
let me jump back I basically said in
looking at the explorers of times past
and when they said hey I'm going to try
to circumnavigate the globe or I'm going
to try to fly a plane across the
Atlantic or I'm going try to climb
Everest or like whatever a person tried
to say they would do for adventure I
said in 2023 what is the most epic
adventure any human could go after and
it was death and so we said okay if
we're going to do this then we want to
go about it in a systematic way so I
built a team of 30 doctors and we comb
through all the scientific literature
every study ever done on lifespan and
healthspan and then we graded each of
them according to these biostatistical
criteria we said which ones have the
best evidence and then we've just
marched through and said okay we're
going to knock out every Power law in
this game and then we've T I've become
the most measured person in human
history and so I say tongue and cheek
blueprint is the best health protocol
built in human history prove me wrong
with your data there's no one more
Quantified ever uh there's no more
evidence you no one who's compiled more
evidence behind it so I'm hoping that
this is useful for people because you
know I certainly could have hid this
behind some pay wall or I could have
been charging for it but I've made it
all for free so everyone can do it yeah
I do actually I do appreciate that I
think it's I think ultimately your your
Pursuit is a is a uh a noble one I think
at least I think I think you know as
it's never happened before I do think it
can have some really far-reaching
benefits for people what kind of stuff
would you say has surprised you the most
that you've learned throughout this
journey it
works that surprised you the most
because I us I was interested in health
and wellness and I would find a doctor
and you know they'd have their own thing
of like here's my understanding of
reality and do these things and I was
always chasing and win some things lose
some things but I've never had whole
body Rejuvenation that science can
uh can J can basically agree with like
that all my data is public and you just
can't refute the data whether you
disagree with like this this test or
that test there's so many at this point
now you know it just works and that's I
didn't think that you could put together
a program and
systematically achieve achieve whole
body wellness and spiritual physical
mental all the above so is there any
downsides in your life to living this
super ultra regimented lifestyle what's
the drawbacks for
you honestly none I know that that's one
of the first things that people assume
is like there's like 10 things like he
must be miserable he's in a cage of his
own making he must be antisocial he must
hate his food he must Des want pizza and
donuts he must desperately want to get
drunk and so there all these assumptions
none are true I've never been happier in
my entire life like I mean I was in I
was in a pretty bad State I was
chronically depressed for 10 years like
I I desperately wanted to take my own
life and I would have had it not been my
three kids so like I it's just like God
is depression it doesn't suck like it's
the worst like every 10 seconds your
brain's like you should commit suicide
thanks you know just like this
omnipresent thing and so yeah just I'm
grateful that I'm alive I'm grateful
that I feel really well um I just have
this deep appreciation for life and so I
don't miss anything that I did before I
used to every night at 7 p.m uh this
version of me evening Brian would be at
the end of the day he would have all the
stress from running a startup I would
have just put together put put the kids
to bed bathed them read them stories got
them in bed and then have a fight with
the partner and then like the world just
fills on fire fire and the only thing
that made sense to me was eat the
brownies in the kid in the kitchen you
know like just go eat to get some kind
of soothe your pain and I put on 50
pounds I was 50 pounds heavier than I am
now I couldn't sleep um I had my top
button of my pants wouldn't button up
because I was overweight it just was
like miserable so I'm just so happy I'm
out of that cycle it was really bad yeah
I are you able to still
maintain healthy family life with this
lifestyle it's so counterintuitively
it's better than it ever has been every
everything in my life is better there's
not a single thing that I would consider
to be a sacrifice and so do you date how
what is that like if you take a date out
and then it's like you don't eat it you
don't I'm assuming you're single just
because you said you were I I think you
mentioned that you were separated from
your partner but uh what's dating Brian
Johnson
like
yeah uh and are you
single I am single yeah there it is
people so it's like
um yeah it's a complicated question
because the most people have
expectations about what is appropriate
for how somebody's in a relationship in
the year 20
2023 and I basically break all Norms
that are in the zist and so one has to
be over that and then two I'm pretty
focused on this endeavor and I don't uh
prioritize relationships as much as
people would expect so yeah
statistically the person that's going to
be compatible with me is just going to
be it's it's going to be hard to find
them they're gonna know they're G yeah
okay that's good it's almost like a
religion that they have to
join I mean so I when I go on dates I I
tell them the 10 reasons why they're
going to hate me and and at what periods
of time it's going to
commence um what's your suest what's
your idea of a perfect date I'm just
curious like what do you guys
do cuz you don't you don't eat bread
probably and butter that's what I like
you sit at dinner you go bread and
butter have a glass of wine you don't do
any of that
stuff uh I'll go on a hike recently I
went to a trampoline
park trampoline park that's kind of fun
date first date yeah I was I was working
on trying to do a flip and I mention no
I suck at it them I want to get better
and and so they were like let's do it
I'm like okay I I I felt a little odd a
little bashful saying we should go to a
trampoline park on the first dat but she
was down with it there you go that's
nice do you watch
television sometimes not a lot what do
you
watch
recently uh South Park is my go-to most
the time
inter yeah so um has there been an
episode about you by the way that's
actually that actually might happen
totally yeah and would you ever eat raw
liver here's you in alternate
universe this oh he can't see
it oh okay never mind then so I I I
wanted to review some more videos of
your routine and then maybe you can
comment on them afterwards if that's
okay cool yeah oh there he can see it
now and whatever so I wanted to watch
your one about your your boner routine
which was pretty interesting and a
little
unexpected but here's the video then I
my night erection how long are you erect
each night and apparently this is an
important question for male men's health
eh
so let's go get those boners on people
anyway here is the uh
video 12 minutes per night inter
erections which is a biological age of
about 49 so 3 years older than my
chronological age I need to see if I can
do some therapies to reduce the
biological age if I'm going to achieve
age 18 of nighttime erections I need to
have 3 hours and 30 minutes so I need to
increase when you're trying to get
18-year-old erection you're you're
you're flying for the sun
brother
all right you know when yeah go ahead
erections by roughly an hour and 20
minutes on that marker blood flow mid
Max urination speed and then penis
plaque will also have these Baseline
measurements to know what therapies we
need to do to rejuvenate the penis I did
my nighttime erections and I average 2
hours and 12 minutes per night in
erections which is a biological age of
about 49 so 3 years older than my
chronological age so wait there was more
there was ones where you were talking
about
uh here here it is here's more where you
were talking about doing injections in
your dick and stuff and I was like y
that's pretty crazy so you've been um
but yeah I guess tell me about your
nighttime uh erection
routine yeah um I I to say that yeah um
I had two scientists approach me at a
longevity conference and they said we
confess we hated you we thought that you
brought embarrassment to the community
and you were bringing shame to our work
geez harsh but they said we now confess
we love you because we never thought
that talking about nighttime erections
and rejuvenating Johnson's Johnson would
be the language that would translate for
people understanding what longevity is
huh this is the bridge people are on
board with penis rejuven Rejuvenation
that that was a moment for me because
they were like you know we thought this
was going to be like a scientific
publication headline that we had done
this protein doing this thing and
they're like actually know people just
care about their penises being
rejuvenated working absolutely man
that's you know I mean at the end of the
day what what else is it really about
why we trying to live forever Brian if
not you know to have you know honestly
that's the bullseye you nailed it I mean
honestly like legit what do what else do
we care about I mean like we have we're
pretty basic creatures and you know when
your health is not well when you're not
sleeping well nighttime erections are
the first thing to go away and so if you
have a zero score it's a really good
invitation to reconsider Your Life
Choices so the the the nighttime
erection isn't the simp it's a
measurement more of your body's Health
it's not it's like the dip stick coming
out you know what I mean or like the air
pressure tire you know when you gauge
it's just it's a measurement it's not
the erection itself that's
causing uh any difference exactly no it
just tells you it's a measurement of
your sexual physiological cardiovascular
health and so tell me about the tell me
about the
routine uh so for we did this Baseline
uh measurement it's just a small little
Cube that you put on the shaft and you
once you put it on you can barely fill
it it uh you forget about it and then at
night I'm curious what it looks like can
you pull it up a cube yeah it's a cube
about um 3/4 of an inch
cubed okay interesting yep and then it
has a a little string around it so that
as the penis becomes erect at night and
enlarges then it measures the
enlargement and so it it measures how
long the penis is erect and what quality
the erection level was and so for
example my last measurement I had five
total erections a duration of like 2
hours and 47 minutes and each one was
around you know 40 something odd minutes
all right something like that and then I
got a 92% erection quality score as an
average among the erection
and I I know that for example when I
sleep poorly because I've traveled or
something that night directions plummet
to sometimes like 30 40 minutes and so
it has a huge impact when you deviate
when you get poor health but then with
some things we've done to try to improve
it we've used electromagnetic therapy so
it's like a can we pull
that sorry I just I was pulling up a
clip of the device I just wanted to see
what it looks like put there you
[Music]
go yeah mine's a little bit bigger have
you got so you tighten it or yeah so you
have that on the okay just at night and
I do yeah I'll do it like three or four
nights in a row when I'm doing the
measurement and then I won't do it for a
month or two so spacing between the
therapies and then I also the boner box
yeah that's a good name yeah and then
does this stuff apply to
women it does so it's the literature
suggest that women also have nitm
erections it's just very hard to measure
it's it's a very yeah it's a difficult
one to get out so there's not as much uh
evidence around nighttime erections for
women although it's it's theorized that
it's happening uh the same as men you
know that interestingly because I feel
when I wake have a nighttime erection I
feel like a lot of times I wake up and
it's like it's a response to having to
pee m is that a thing or is that just me
I don't know I'm not sure they may
coincide yeah I mean if you remember
like when you were a kid when you were
13 14 like I was erect all the time you
know like you're walking in between
class and like you just become erect
it's like God damn it my pants are
bulging I have to put my book over my
pants because I'm embarrassed yeah it's
horrific it just naturally happens and
as time it goes down so yeah so we also
I also did this electromagnetic uh or
this Focus shock wave therapy so it's um
a little device it's used for whole body
so it fires these acoustical waves into
the body body it's used for like tendons
ligaments all the joints in the body
it's also used for erectile dysfunction
so while I don't have erectile
dysfunction my sexual performance scores
are all perfect uh we theorized if it's
helpful for Ed and some people let's try
it for the therapy enhancement so we
gave it a go and uh we did see an
improvement in nighttime erections I'm
not yet at an 18-year-old level we're
not sure if we can identify any therapy
that can get us there we're making slow
progress but uh it's been a hard one
yeah so you say you have a perfect score
on sexual Wellness is that something you
bring up on the first date or
no listen
I I want to tell you up front I've got
the erection of a
18-year-old no thank you anyway uh let's
keep watching or no we already saw
it so what what is it that you're doing
though cuz I saw you talking about
putting injections in your penis and
that's that doesn't seem like something
that many people would be willing to do
yeah we were looking at so we were
trying to create the most Quantified
penis ever and so we said we looked at
all the evidence and we said what is
every single test we can do to quantify
the function of my penis and so we said
we can do nighttime erections we can
look at penile blood flow so when you
get erect you've got a certain flow rate
of blood in your penis and so the
injection was looking using Ultrasound
with an erect penis to look at blood
flow and you can age score that as you
age you have less blood flow in the
penis so by having that measurement
protocol you're you're seeing if there's
improvements and it's also a marker when
you're looking at Focus shock wave
therapy to see if that's improving
because Focus shock wave therapy is
supposed to improve those kinds of
characteristics and then I was doing the
maximum uh urine flow Max pen and uh we
did Ultrasound with the prostate of the
bladder uh oh we just got a new
technology is coming in this week
looking at um the tip of the shaft
sensitivity so we can measure that hold
the phone how do you measure that yeah
we just we just found this guy he has
flashlight uh it's a it's a device we we
just talked about it this week um it's
used to measure sensitivity around the
body uh a penis is one application so
we're going to use that on the the tip
to to quantify sensitivity which is
another like for example um we measured
my nerve sensitivity And my heels and uh
I've got three and a half MERS of
sensitivity you bring two points and you
start very narrow and you get larger and
larger and as you age you get less
sensitive so like an 80 or 90-year-old
like they'd have sensitivity you know
like an inch or two or three I forget
what the number is but young young
people have a sensitivity because your
nerves just Decay and so my nerve
sensitivity had actually improved since
starting blueprint I think my age marker
was like 22 or something like that so
yeah we're looking at basically
degradation of the of nerves throughout
the body from sexual function to uh feet
and um what is the significance of P
strength I'll admit my PE strength is
not what it used to be and I I'll tell
you we have young boys and seeing them
pee has reminded me of the of what we
used to have cuz y all remember like
being in elementary school you would
stand like 20 ft back from the
Ural and slam it in there
time uh and I just I don't have that
that strength like I did Brian exactly
so what do yeah yeah so this is the cool
thing I
mean but why is that
important uh because the body degrades
across all systems over time and we're
trying to demonstrate that you can
isolate these systems with robust
measurement you can look at scientific
evidence and then reverse it let's just
be honest like we want we want to all be
kids sitting back 5 feet having peeing
contest that's fun and the older you get
you can't do it anymore and it kind of
sucks right and so I'm really I I
realize that uh what I do appears to be
ridiculous like I'm fully self-aware of
the entire situation
also like we you know it sucks to get
old and it sucks when these things
degrade and so we're really trying to to
demonstrate that um you can do something
about age to slow it down and even even
reverse it
mhm um here is another one that I wanted
to ask you about this is this has been
going around the whole blood the blood
of your son you guys have like a Blood
Waterfall going on where your son is
putting his blood in you and you're
putting your blood in your dad and
everybody's getting younger somehow your
son's the only one frankly who needs
blood we need to get him some baby blood
or
something did you see the results that
my dad had I I I I did I saw you had
mentioned that it had a significant uh
positive impact on your dad right yeah
lowered his speed of Aging by 25 years
he went from aging at his pace of a 71y
old to the age of to the speed of a 46
year old and has that measurement
continued to stay around yeah we he we
did three measurements before the
therapy this is using DNA methylation
patterns and we did three measurements
after the therapy the last one six
months post therapy and it's still the
effect still persisted
wow just from the blood do you think
there's anything else going on or just
because you got that blood and by the
way how much can I buy some of that yeah
there there's two things one is he had
600 milliliters of his plasma removed
and then one liter of my plasma infused
so it's not clear was the effect due to
him removing his stuff or infusing my
stuff or both to some combo well people
lose lots of blood all the time it
doesn't deedge them do you need to do
that regularly given blood you do uh so
we we've we've just done it once yeah
that's the thing is the we we just did
it one time and we wanted to see if it
would work but you know like my dad's 70
years old he he works in law and he was
telling me that he did a brief and then
he left his desk went back to his desk
and it was a jumbled mess and he he
became so shocked because he was unaware
that his mind was a jumbled mess he it
was basically his his um loss of
cognitive capacity was invisible to himh
and he became terrified he called me
he's like hey I need to tell you
something this is very alarming and I
said okay Dad we're actually we're
talking about these plasma things this
week as a team I just I've been doing a
few of these I'd be happy to do this
with you and so like it was such a
special moment for like my dad is like
trying to hang on to his cognitive
existence and when you if you ask him
about how he's felt post the infusion uh
he'll report has changed his life life
like he just feels different mhm so I
wonder how can we how could you possibly
uh extend
that um to a wider populace because you
just have that you've got that good
blood and um I can't imagine that you
you'd be happy to start selling that out
yeah the cool thing is there's several
companies working on the technology that
would make this possible without other
humans needing to do it so they they
build the therapy in the lab and that
way everyone could get access to it and
you wouldn't need to do this personto
person so so people are they they can
make blood essentially with the
composition of your blood basically yeah
because you're you're pull you're
grabbing the blood you separate plasma
from blood and you're just working with
the plasma basically the good things in
the plasma that potentially cause the
effect Andor uh removing the stuff in
the plasma that causes the effect both
are options and so this is what I'm
saying why it's set an exciting time to
live is these things are in process
they're uh very close and we are going
to be able to dramatically slow our
aging and reverse it uh in ways that
probably um Bend our imagination right
now and it's so close that is very
interesting yeah here's the video of uh
you and your son how old is your son
he's 18 now oh okay very young
man and has his blood uh that benefited
you we couldn't identify uh a difference
in my blood or in my markers so if it
did have a positive effect we haven't
been able to identify it yet uh it's
possible though that you know my markers
are so close to my son's right
now maybe just not maybe not enough of a
difference whereas like if you compare
my dad's markers to mine there's such a
big difference right that it's sensible
that there was a a change so if your son
gave your dad blood would it have
theoretically a stronger effect I mean
that's the thing my son's blood and mine
are is about the same yeah if you look
at various markers so I don't know maybe
it seems like how the blood transfusion
thing seems like I'm surprised that this
hasn't been observed before because
people are donating and receiving blood
all the time for for for centuries
right yeah it's pretty recent literature
I mean it was shown in animals first
with the that famous experiment but then
recently in humans there's some
interesting clinical trials going on
around Alzheimer's and Parkinson's but
yeah it's definitely I I go ahead
they're they're experimenting with
treating Alzheimer's and Parkinson with
blood transfusions exactly yeah that's
why that's why I brought my dad in
because there's some encouraging
evidence early evidence on it it's not
conclusive yet still an emergent space
so it's really experimental therapy but
it it's you know like we saw it in my
dad and my dad has experienced the
benefit
that's interesting that would be amazing
if that became like a whole new medical
vertical of just like blood transfusion
sounds something so doable yeah
totally there it is here let me let me
uh got a load of this here physical
symptoms everything and his
reconciliation and he had to pull
himself apart and so as he's gone
through that process then he's been able
to look at me and say ah I get it you
know it was not an act of Cruelty a
misjudgment you know lack of character
and uh and so that has resulted in in
what I see is this kind of
unification where we get each other you
know Dad's getting emotion here the
three you guys are is this your only son
yes I I have two other children I have
two sons uh two boys and a girl was this
the only guy who was willing to get
involved in this the
[Laughter]
shenanigans uh he was he was a he was
the willing participant yes that's good
um here is some photos we grabbed don't
die what what do
we what do we do about it
yeah um so if you take stock of this
moment where artificial intelligence is
improving at a speed that we can't
understand it's so fast that we can't
understand it and we've got potential
climate collapse of some sort and we
humans are dangerously at each other's
throats what as a species do we do how
do we solve problems before they ruin
existence and I thought about this
question for years and when you look out
in the world and say okay What
ideologies in the world are actually
helpful can we ask religions what they
think are they going to offer anything
helpful no can we turn to capitalism and
have that solve our problem not really
same with socialism same with so like
you look out in the world and say like
who who has a framework to help us think
how to practically solve day-to-day
problems on how we not destroy ourselves
and don't die is the philosophy I came
up with zero this called zero ISM of
like a practical and holistic
perspective on how do we as a species
survive ourselves and build an amazing
future well one of my questions for you
is this are you sure that living longer
is going to be better for society a lot
of times especially as you mentioned
Society we are progressing so quickly
that frankly um change only happens our
in our society when the older generation
starts dying and um the the new ideas
are allowed to become
mainstream um and so I wonder if this is
a good thing people living to 200 years
old or so or whatever it is you you
imagine that we could be living too yeah
here's a different way of thinking about
it is don't die is the most played game
out of anything in existence by everyone
in the world every second of the day
there's no game more people play so like
in this moment the three of us are
playing don't die we breathe every few
seconds to make sure we have enough
oxygen if anything were to uh threaten
Our Lives we would immediately stop this
conversation and protect our lives we
look both ways before we cross the
street we throw out moldy Foods we are
omnipresent concerned about not dying
and we've just simply as a society we've
gotten a lot better at not dying our you
know our life expectancies are doubled
than what they used to be the future is
just simply getting really really really
good at not dying and that's what I've
done in in Blueprint is I basically as
being the most measured person in
history we have figured out all the way
not figured out we have identified as
many ways as we can all the ways I die
on a minute to- minute basis and we've
then tried to reduce those and so that's
what it's about is playing the same game
we're all playing right now and like
right now we don't want to die like no
one wants to die I mean that's not true
most people don't want to die really
yeah well so what is the life expectancy
that you think is realistic uh with
these methods you're working on now
short of immortality of course yeah
which you seem to be potentially
convinced of this is the thing
uh I am the equivalent of homo erectus I
have AB I am a
caveman I have nothing intelligent to
say about the future that's the thing is
if you really understand where
artificial intelligence is
at it invokes a humility that we are
primitive we have no idea what's going
what's coming and that's why I the don't
die is the only the only thing I know in
existence is don't die and the the
philosophy is applicable to you like the
health of our planet matters like we
need a stable biosphere to support life
on this planet and right now we're not
doing a great job and blueprint is
equally is applicable to the planet just
replace my body with the earth and the
same process applies you measure Earth
with millions of measurements you look
at the scientific evidence and say what
is a healthy ocean look like what are
what's healthy soil what's a healthy
biosphere what's healthy air you
implement the protocols and then you do
it again and again but we treat planet
Earth just like we treat our bodies we
have the exact same relationship with
both entities and people don't realize
that that that that this is what I'm
trying to do is this is about individual
health yes but it's about don't die
individually don't kill each other don't
kill the planet and align AI with don't
die it is the only philosophy that is
relevant in this moment in
time so say some tech came around that
was like revolutionary to the point of
saying basically we found a way for
cells to self uh do duplicate perfectly
and the aging process is just it stopped
we don't age anymore do you think that
that's something ethical and worth
pursuing um that kind of
Technology oftentimes the problems we
think about in society don't end up
being the problems that actually we care
about so an example of this is in when
in early 1900s New York horse manure was
the biggest problem there because horse
was the primary mode of transportation
manure was everywhere it was in the
Hudson River it caused disease uh they
couldn't eliminate it fast enough and so
the world was coming to an end and they
couldn't solve the problem and then
Henry Ford made the Model T and the car
made horses uh irrelevant so the the
manure problem went away so what they
thought was an existential problem
wasn't in fact the existential problem
now the car created other problems that
were the real problems and right now I
I'm not sure if we know what the real
problems are I hear your question you
know we can apply we can take 2023
ethics and morals and apply to a certain
question but to me it's just like
looking backwards we're not really
mapping is it possible though that
you're avoiding somehow uh convince it
seems like you've justified in your mind
avoiding thinking about the difficult um
side this the the difficult effect to to
Grapple with of what these long SL
Immortal lives uh mean for Humanity and
the world because I do think you know
it's we can say like yeah the future is
unknown and we're insignificant but at
the same time it is I think important
and very possible to you know uh uh to
Muse on it to think about on it to think
about the importance of it I mean you
could say the same about AI people we
don't know where AI is going but we sure
we sure do need to be having
conversations about the future and what
it might look like and how to you know
prevent or encourage certain
outcomes yeah
um you know
99% of what we say on a daily basis we
are regurgitating opinions perspectives
and viewpoints of the current
Zeitgeist to say something truly novel
takes tremendous effort and so I could
whip up words and speculate about this
or that it's meaningless my refusal to
answer the question is actually more
valuable because what I'm trying to do
is I'm acknowledging I am an absolute
primitive creature relative to the
Intelligence on the horizon and the
future of intelligence is not knowing we
humans have answers for everything we
want to run our mouths at every moment
for every little thing and for us to
admit that we don't know it's the most
uncomfortable thing in the entire world
but that's the future of our existence
is that we don't know and so if you look
back at it like two like 20 30 20 30
years ago even like 500 years a ago you
could look at the past and look at the
future and say you know what I have a
pretty good idea what's going to happen
I'm going to go to school I'm going to
learn this thing I'm going to have a
career in this thing I'm gonna have a
few kids and uh right now you cannot
model out 12 months from now never in
the history of humanity has the Future
Been a wall of fog and that is the case
right now we do not know and so I'd
rather leaning to that do not know then
run my mouth and say something that
parrots existing Z guys because it's
just the past like these are ideas of
dead people I'd rather look forward and
see if I can figure out something novel
and
interesting people are asking if you
have thoughts on
teir telr I don't even know what that
is uh
it's extending telem is currently if I'm
not mistaken the number one lifespan uh
study ever and so I just did my first
gene therapy it was ranked number seven
as the best ever done H had evidence of
over a 30% lifespan increase in mice so
I we uh yeah so which we we do take some
of those studies and and do translation
to human do you use this these medicines
or I guess they're are they not
applicable yet available to yeah the
gene therapy I did is on a protein
called fost Statin and if you if you
Google fatan cow or faten dog you'll see
that they're like this incredibly
muscled animal so it's like a people
associate this with bodybuilding but it
has all the kinds of benefit effects so
um yes I think that uh Tere gene therapy
will be accessible in the next 18 to 24
months and it it could dramatically
change the landscape of Aging so the
question the person who ask the
questions is spoton it's like that's a
really good area to focus on what what
is the treatment what does it
do the the therapy I did is um it's
delivered a plasmid and so basically I
got two injections on each side of my
stomach and it just inserted uh there
some stuff inside my nuc my cell and it
produces more of this protein
foltin and by having higher level so I
did this injection six 14 days later I
measured my levels it increased by 160%
and so the therapy worked in terms of
increasing my levels and uh yeah it's
the most powerful therapy we've done to
date and what's cool about it is we've
been trying to do gene therapy for the
past two years but we haven't done it
because we've never found one that's
safe enough because you do gene therapy
and you can't turn it off so if it
starts running away and you want to stop
it you can't stop it and that can lead
to cancer and so we this one has an off
switch a kill switch so if you don't
like the situation you can just kill it
with Tetra Tetra cycling and so these
new Gene therapies this is what I'm
talking about is like
I I'm going to go from
crazy to trendy in some
incredibly short period of time when
these things start hitting people will
be like oh damn okay uh this is real
it's accessible it's easy like these
Gene therapies are very powerful and
they're coming so like it is like I'm
telling you it is here and I would
encourage all of you to don't die like
just every single day die everybody be
mindful uh this we're potentially
sitting after four and a half billion
years on this Earth we are at the cusp
of of potentially the most exciting
moment in the history of this galaxy
it's us in this moment I want to be
around for it I mean whatever it is I
want to see it you ever thought about
the the idiot who's the last person to
die like what a
loser and he's just like the last one
and everyone else gets to live
forever I mean I you know sometimes I
cry myself to sleep they'll thinking
about that's my parents you know like my
parents are so like that is a sad Twist
on they're like they're like 70s right
and so like I'm I'm desperately trying
to keep my parents alive like they joke
they like Brian look we appreciate it
but we get a package every day from you
sometimes it's too much like you you got
you know like so but know I really I
want my parents to live uh we're so
close to these breakthroughs ah that is
interesting that is really cool sucks to
be old at this
point but uh it sucks to be old at any
point um there's another question here
from Chad about uh somebody wanted to
know are you are you how familiar with
like Ai and all this kind of stuff you
follow all that I do so somebody
asks if you agree well Ray Kur Wild's
Singularity
prediction I don't know if you're I I
don't know yeah yeah raise a
friend so what are what are your
thoughts on that I'm try he predicts the
singularity will coincide with the next
Epoch the merger of human technology
with human intelligence after the
singularity he says the final Epoch will
C the universe wakes up he
says thoughts
yeah I um I think this is the most
exciting time in 4.5 billion years to
exist on this
Earth and uh man what an exciting
prospect yeah um Ry has been go ahead go
ahead no you go ahead Ray's been
modeling out the future for a few
decades he's tried to take the guesswork
out of and he's tried to say all right
mathematically if we model
out the elements that contribute to the
power of computational intelligence like
transistors and you know a whole bunch
of things how can you think about
modeling out what intelligence does at
What stages and so he's modeled out I
think the singularity is going to happen
in uh 2029 if I'm not mistaken like six
years and this is you know whether ra is
right or wrong doesn't really matter
it's not 500 years and it is here here
right now and that's why I go back to
this don't die philosophy is if we
really are on this cusp of some
explosion and intelligence that's going
to change our fabric of
reality the only thing we care about is
not dying it's the only thing
intelligence cares about once it gets to
a certain stage and so that includes
don't die individually don't kill each
other don't kill the planet and when AI
is here you want to align it so you
don't die so it doesn't kill you so
that's again why like this is what is
the singular thing in existence that we
care about and I think don't die is just
a little bit ahead of it time in terms
of like it will make sense uh you know
every day it'll make a bit more sense
with the reality of where things are at
in the world but once intelligence
reaches a certain stage uh that's all it
cares about is its continued existence
and so Singularity being like the point
where AI becomes like able to forward
its own intelligence is that what it is
and it just becomes like an exponential
increase in computer
intelligence yeah like for a Layman's uh
interpretation it's like when we merge
with computational intelligence and
we're not quite sure where we begin and
it ends we're just one
thing so what does that look like though
you're talking about like putting
computer chips in the human brain and
all that kind of stuff I mean we already
have it in our smartphones today if you
look at our usage and how much we rely
upon it for information and emotional
soothing and entertainment and arousal
we're already pretty tightly coordinated
with our with our technology and as it
become more becomes more ubiquitous but
even it doesn't have to be a chip in the
brain I mean you think about people
taking like OIC you know like even
though that's for weight loss it's a
pill that fundamentally changes your
relationship with food you know you
don't have hunger anymore and your body
drops weight that pill is changing you
as a human it changes your conscious
experience that's just one pill and you
look at the ability we have to now
create uh drugs it's phenomenal and so
we'll be able to to alter our conscious
experience we'll be able to alter the
way we understand reality like these
things are all coming to real um after I
sold brain tree venmo I invested um a
lot of money in deep Tech which is like
synthetic biology Precision chemistry
like these deep science areas and these
companies are doing things like they're
building molecules atom by atom like
Legos we have that kind of ability to to
build these structures or synthetic
biology you can take an organism like
eoli and you can reprogram it so it
manufactures rose oil for you so instead
of growing a rose oil plant fertilizing
it harvesting it get the rose oil you
just have biology build it for you so we
already have these abilties to engineer
the physical and biological and digital
world so we have our fingers on our
ability to literally program reality at
every single layer MH and this is what
it happens when you we start merging
increasingly closer our intellig our
tools of intelligence and ourselves this
is where it gets into this um tapestry
of we're not quite sure where the
boundary conditions are for oursel and
others and
intelligence yeah the the dystopian um
you know prediction of that is basically
just that this highlevel Tech is only
available to the ultra wealthy where you
get because I would imagine at at first
it would be extraordinarily expensive
and hard to do correctly when the
technology first comes out as with all
technology usually is but then like once
you get this ability you kind of there's
a runaway there's kind of an exponential
running away factor and so you know that
combined with like the ability to like
engineer the intelligence of your babies
which is going to be something that rich
people will have access to soon I
believe and stuff like that it seems
like there is a risk I see in the
dystopian version of the future where
there's not just a disparity in wealth
but also a disparity in longevity
technology like uh uh uh uh medical to
the point of like almost survival
different world you're just in a
different world completely you know and
like how do you catch up once you've
shot off on that rocket before
cu the growth is so fast once you the
singularity
happens yeah this is where I think it's
a unique time to exist because in any
other time period I think it would have
been reasonable to map out what you said
and basically what you your assumptions
were you said that you believe the
current systems of human behavior and
status and social class and wealth and
access are going to map over to the
future and that mapping the future just
means it it takes some better things and
it runs them down their course and I'm
suggesting um we cannot map anything
that we understand to be reality today
into this future we are no longer the
alpha
intelligence and while we are the ones
building artificial intelligence it's
not going to stay in our domain uh imp
perpetuity it's going to take on some
amorphous Direction like something that
no one can predict
and I don't think we can say anything
about what we will care about what
societal rules will be what our ethics
and morals would be I just don't think
we're going to have that we're not going
to be in that position of clear
Authority like we are right now like we
have been building society and it breaks
our brains to think about this because
this is the only reality we've we've
ever understood but when you look at the
situations where artificial intelligence
has been truly applied to certain areas
it breaks all rules like you take it
when it played Alpha go it beat the 19
time World Champ champ of the game go
and it got in there in a few hours it
broke the game go thousands of years of
human genius uh was was uh triumphed by
this artificial intelligence and it
played from a different dimension and
you now take these increasingly powerful
tools it's going to rewrite reality in
every way and so again like you come
back to okay what can we say about the
future that's even remotely intelligent
don't die outside of that I don't know
if we can say anything intelligent
assume anything for
reason okay I mean I see what you're
saying I do feel that there's an element
of convenience to that uh you know what
I mean to to that excuse to to any of
the challenging questions however I do
know I do understand also where you're
coming from I'll say um uh is there
anything you want to share with us
anything you want to tell us uh that
that's going on before we we say goodbye
yeah I mean I want to say that um you
know the people dunking on me it's cool
I mean so so carry on like you know it's
all it's all in good fun uh I think it's
great I love dunking on myself so
clowning me is cool um I just want to
say sincerely to each one of
you um this is real and like you know
doing basic things in your life like
going to bed on time getting exercise
eating
well uh they can make meaningful
differences in your conscious experience
of life and I just would encourage you
to prioritize your health and in
particular your sleep make it your
number one life priority nothing's more
important and nothing will make you a
better person than getting high quality
sleep routinely and it's just like
having you know good physique it doesn't
just happen by on its own you have to
work every day and work really hard at
it the same as true as sleep and the
most important thing each one of us can
have is a clear head and you know
regulated emotions in life and when
we're sleep deprived life is just
increasing you know pretty challenging
so yeah I hope this conversation
actually if it did anything I hope it
encourages you to invest in your your uh
Health just at a minimum because it
improves the quality of your life there
it is that's good yeah sleep guys don't
sleep on sleep they
say but I'll tell you I I appreciate you
calling in I think you're super
interesting dude appreciate very much
that you're um that you have like a a a
good attitude about everything and all
the you know the the trolls online and
stuff and that you're self-aware playful
with it I think that's that's the the
perfect way to to uh deal with all this
stuff but I I I I think you're on to
something really uh exciting and I'll
continue to follow uh as I have
been yeah thanks guys for having me this
was fun cool thank you so much and uh
maybe we'll we'll talk again soon uh
we'll we'll touch back every 10 years
until one of us
dies all right all right bye Brian
thanks for the call thanks Brian thank
you thank
you have a good night interesting fella
yeah definitely yeah he's not he's not
he is good I like what he's I like his
whole thing you know what I mean I mean
rich people they can just sit up in
their towers but he I feel like you know
he is trying to do
something obviously self-serving but it
does have benefits to MH to everybody I
think potentially
so there it is Brian he did siep that
um that question that you asked at the
end I thought was a really good one and
um I was right he didn't have a good
answer for that you think that I was
right and I'm no I think that's a real
concern AB convenient he just all of a
sudden can't can't think about it I
think that answer came up too much of
like every time it's almost like well I
can't tell what will be in the future so
nothing matters well it like I
understand where he's coming
however the idea of an AI
Revolution creating like a perfect
communistic classless society is pretty
much zero the more likely outcome is
that it's going to make rich people
richer and more powerful and and harder
to catch up like you said just like a
runaway effect for certain class of
people but what can you do it's
unavoidable this this is what it
is but
um but yeah really cool
and the one thing about sleep where he's
like prioritized getting
sleep it's just when you have little kid
kids it's like you you literally can't
yeah he would give you a pass probably
for that but most people have some stuff
going on in their life you I mean I I
can't just get in bed and fall asleep
though I'm not like that
too I don't have that ability mhm I mean
but it's like he said maybe with
practice you get
I can't that's me every night it's a
damn nightmare Brian I want to
sleep any thoughts interesting food for
thought I am also getting like my
internal intuition is feeling skeptical
of things but at the same time I find it
interesting MH I don't think he's
harming anybody so no so there's no harm
being done yeah as far as I know I
haven't looked in his basement but
as far as we know
yeah um my God uh my avery Mega awesome
ner said as long as AI gives me fortnite
I will obey our AI overlords fornite we
need Super fortnite as long as my brain
is Zapped into fortnite we're good and I
had one other thought that I kept
thinking like it seems like his life
right now seems too difficult to the
point where I wouldn't care that much to
try to do everything that he does MH and
I think to make something really
revolutionary it needs to be like easy
and accessible like the way a zic is
like just something you take and it
changes your life right I think real
progress will be when it's like that
easy and you don't have to put so much
effort and like change your whole life
meaning needs to be about this project
right I think it's I I don't know if I
think what I was getting is that there's
a lot of little things that contribute
but it seems like there's a few big
things that make all the difference I
don't know what this experimental
medicine coming up is but that sounds
really really incredible potentially mhm
you know seems like a nice guy though we
like
Brian we're fan of Brian's here on the
H3 podcast we love all
Bryan um except Brian Singer we do not
like Brian
Singer we do not like him all right we
got to thank our sponsors and then we
will um we do get into the and I have a
surprise for you guys for me for both of
you is it and Bros hm is it and brothers
well let's do the ad read and I'll bust
it out is it better be what kind of
surprise it's not a
surprise you're not saying no what is it
I'm I cannot confirm or deny anything
God I'm so hungry I want Ambrose we got
to order I wanted chocolate right before
the show I was like looking for
chocolate you heard El was begging for
chocolate Dan you didn't paper I got ose
the saying is like the surprise now
would you like the surprise now no let's
do the ad read first I don't want to I
don't want it to get push back anymore
all right thank you so much to hex
clad I am such a huge fan of these guys
first of all thank you for supporting us
consider supporting why am I doing that
consider supporting them uh during this
holiday season you know I keep trying to
have my pan in here but I I need it at
home I take it home yeah I was like yo
where's the pan oh I took it home none
of us that have them want to leave them
here because they're our best pans and I
never bring anything home how much
do I leave here all the time you know
your wallet all the time like my clothes
all the time yes Shrek ears for my
Crocs um huge huge fan of their
beautiful products uh let me see
here um let me pull up one of these
videos get a little bit
I'm a little guy named Gordon maybe
you've heard of him uh Gordon
Ramses ramsy the
third ramsy's I fell in love with hex
glads a few years back a chef friend of
mine sent me a 12 in non-stick pan as a
gift it was a joy to work with something
that I took to immediately as a front
runner in the industry they're raising
the bar my level of perfection connects
with that bar and more importantly as a
collaboration together I think we would
become one of the most exciting brands
on the planet you said it bro you said
it here let me go to the website it's
like this incred this really cool
technology where
um there's like hexagonal shape in the
pan mhm and it's uh
non-stick even cooking it doesn't
scratch they say scratch proof and so
far I I've been using that thing for
prob over a year now scratches no it's
perfectly clean same here right it's
crazy once you clean it it's like a
brand new pot it's crazy I've never
owned a pan like that and we've bought
nice stuff before but uh this one looks
brand new after a year of frequent use
it is it is really quite something M I
got a whole bunch of them I've been
dulling it out to my family everybody's
loving it everybody wants more it's
hexclad it's all happening great gift an
Incredible Gift uh
during this holiday season but yeah if
you guys are in the market for some pans
one that's going to last you long long
time consider going with hexclad
um find your Forever cookware at hexclad
and get 10% off at
hex.exe and you know listen Gord if it's
good enough for Gordon it's good enough
for me you know what I'm
saying as long as he's not cooking any
grilled cheese in
it you seen that I have I think I know
horrific just horrific but anyway thank
you so much to hexclad love you and
thank you for sponsoring us and please
consider supporting them thank you thank
you love hex
Cloud Sure do we are a hex Cloud family
thank you to
games
Subs
gamer
Subs Sigma brain brain give it up charge
up right now this is our proprietary
exclusive H3 podcast flavor spicy
Margarita but we call it Sigma brain
don't think it's spicy though don't when
I say spicy Margarita it's not spicy at
all it's just a fun
little sensation the vibe yeah but it's
a perfect nice um lemon lime perfect
balance of citrus and sweetness and I'll
tell you what sugar-free it's
caffeinated and uh it's super hydrating
it's enriched with all kinds of
essential vitamins and minerals this is
the ultimate
drink and it's really
good excuse
me and there is a big caffeinated one as
well true um they they're running some
pretty cool stuff here let's see gamer
Subs is launching our new waifu cup
Heaven and Hell with matching hoodie and
sweatpants oh my goodness I don't think
I can show you guys the photos because
they're very
graphic right I mean I don't here I'll
show you Ela let see like that's a lot
really we can't show that you don't
think so come on YouTube I don't know I
just I don't know if I'm going to risk
it that one's whatever oh hold on
there's ones with like some big ass
anime titties basically you know that
ain't
illegal big ass an hell no hell no make
big anime titties
legal um so they're giving
away
uh giving away or no they've got the new
hoodie and CBS they're also running a
deal here you get items for free the
deals do stack here's the here's the
platforms here the tiers $30 free
sticker pack cute $50 free set of gaming
sleeves what is gaming sleeves a gaming
sleeve is that to like keep prevent
chafing do you know what that is love I
remember probably uh like um mouse or
like um when you move the mouse
like that wow oh no you know what it's
just to make sure you have a straight
wrist I think when you're moving your
your wait for real that's my guess hold
on let's look it up I'm actually scared
I think it just looks cool I thought it
was a gamer but apparently not it's just
epic gamer moment here I don't know I do
I think it does have some kind of
purpose cuz you really do your
wrist up if you play a lot of games
that's true I had massive wrist issues
for a while huh just get those gamer
sleeves on
people you
know be the Ultimate Gamer I born always
use protection when you game $75 you get
a free shirt $100 you get a free
Guardian Angel waifu jug and those
aren't the only jugs you'll be seeing
hell yeah and $150 you get a free
sweater and if you spend 150 you get all
that stuff basically for free yeah but
we we were in the lab we calculated the
perfect flavor we went back and forth
for a long time to come up with Sigma
brain so I hope you guys will enjoy it
give it a try I'm pretty sure you will
love it go to gamersupps.gg and use the
code H3 to get 10% off your first order
that is gamersupps.gg use the code H3 to
get 10% off your first order thank you
thank you no 10% off your order period I
don't think it even needs to be your
first one okay code H3 to get 10% off
your order yeah any order there it is
Bob's your uncle w wow all right
everybody thank you to our sponsors
please consider supporting and thank you
have to run to the okay well Dan's going
to do his surprise no she needs to be
here for it all right ela's running to
the bathroom here um one second um
there's another surprise um for you
right now that we could do in the
meantime here we go it's my it's my boy
it's Gabe how's it
[Music]
going looking good huh sipping on some
sodi today's my cheat day baby today my
cheat day a I I love the cheat day are
you at
flukies don't dox him oh okay well he's
not anyways what are you eating I'm
having a I'm having a slice of pizza as
my cheat day baby nice how many slices
you gonna kick down just one just
one wow that is so responsible just to
have one slice that that's impressive
that's not easy to do
yeah that's awesome man and is that a
full body Cola or is that a diet
cola a diet cola That's my boy
you you're doing great you're killing it
appreciate the love
support of course always buddy are we
going to see you at the live show you'll
be there right sure yeah I'm gonna be we
have a we have a we have a fun gag
planned for us all right I don't know if
you been briefed on our fun
gag he has yes oh okay cool yeah it'd be
fun it was going to be really fun
um we'll Pro yeah gonna make a joke but
I backed off it real fast but Gabe um
nice nice to see you any plans this
weekend I'm going to my cousin's party
and then I'm having my suit tailored for
the live show ah nice very good my red
suit baby hell yeah well I look forward
to seeing you there Gabe and uh well
we'll talk to you next Friday before
that but um always nice see here for me
enjoy your cheat meal we love we love
you we love your beautiful face you're
doing so well and we're all very happy
thank you with all my love and support
you guys did you know I made it through
and many more many more days to come or
month hell yeah dude all right Gabe
we'll talk to you soon appreciate you
brother sure all right
um
hello
all right gab take care all right all
[Music]
right
Chow all right thank you let's get to
the
chocolate ni let's get to the chocolate
what's the surprise what chocolate all
right what's the surprise then give me
one sec I'll go get it are you okay he
just going to go get the chocolate it
has to be Anson's there's no other
possibility frankly if it's anything
else I'm going to be disappointed I'm
going to flip the table and leave I know
I'm going to close the show I'm ending
the show yeah permanently I'm going
home my God I got a sneak peek okay I
recognize that bag let's go
wow do you have some or is this do you
guys have some back
there oh and I uh save some for Sam
she's downstairs you made sure to tell
me when I grabbed it from it card from
Jeff here let's see jingle balls almond
Prine and peppermint ganach oh that's
the new thing he said yeah and then
there's their uh their winter box in
there too wait there's only one box in
here honored to be the official
chocolate here of the podcast is one box
we will keep the chocolate flowing Fu
did somebody steal it Chef Sandy brother
Phil and Mark wow this is not keeping
the chocolate flowing
this is a room full of it just makes me
kind of mad just makes me kind of angry
you know who delivered
it oh I take it back no no no okay
somebody fess up
somebody yes who did that who did that
are you serious yeah it was all in the
bag that's why I just grabbed a bag and
this was sitting over there you look you
look suspicious I'm hungry give me one
right now I don't care who did it I just
want one right to be fair this looks
like the perfect to be fair it is it
does appear to be sealed so unless they
did some sort of surgical entry here
it's sealed guys yeah but somebody was
digging through somebody was rustling
just probably took a little look here
what's in the bag I don't know who would
do that this is one of my favorite
things they've made wow this is so good
you guys got to try this peppermint
ganache holy you want one more
there one more and then pass it yeah
pass that wow this is so good so I
believe that he told me those uh those
will be available next Monday they're
dropping the the praline or what
whatever it was you just said peint
peppermint oh my and there's like an
almond thing in there too right half
mint half chocolate M that's crazy dog
that's crazy
right the outer shell is really good too
mhm which side is which do we know no I
want the Almond one no those are all the
same oh they're all the same yeah this
is the other one I think at least I had
two they're both the same ooh
T tastes like after eight this is why
we're
here this is why we're here this is why
we do what we do people this is why I
wake up wake up
uhhuh it t like be jerky let's try some
of these new ones I don't know which one
to go
for
M I got that one good yeah M
mhm
M I feel like I only ever want to eat
half because I want to try another one
but I'll die if I eat all the chocolate
I want wow this one has like coffee in
it oh is that what it is so good
M oh oh oh hit it don't do it to
him okay I'm going to try one more and
I'll pass it
around H hey Brian Johnson this is
living dude this is real living this is
real living you know what Brian who
wants to live
forever who wants to live
forever I got the gold one so
true I
me if rich people started Living
forever that would not be a net good a
nightmare nightmare like how many of the
younger generation is like I just want
the old people to die off so we can
progress MH I thought that was a really
good question thank you how many of the
younger Generations just like I want a
house right right let's focus on
that what's the point of living forever
if
you're you know well more time to
save I did kind of want to ask him but
you you asked a similar question so it
felt a little redundant but you know
there is like
a huge body of thought and philosophy
and religion on the concept of death and
you know often times sort
of coming to a conclusion that death is
something that actually gives uh meaning
to a human's life and um there's so much
like um fiction and uh uh and
non-fiction but so many stories are are
about the curse of immortality and how
it's like a monkey wish to live forever
and everything and I I wonder if he's
like that that's just cope wonder if
that's kind of like his attitude he
doesn't think he's living forever though
I find it interesting he would like if
he was like 200 yeah I mean he seemed
some like it's funny saying he's
realistic uh maybe not necessarily
realistic is the right word but seems um
seems to hedge what he's saying a little
bit in that you know maybe maybe not
forever but I we'll start with just
extending Our Lives to you know 100 or
something I did get a feeling that he's
very well trained already on what to say
and what not to say kind of yeah I'm
sure he gets lot smart questions yeah
he's a smart guy he should read Tuck
Everlasting I read that in fifth grade
book club about immortality and how you
should have wanted well it's it's one of
the great themes of
U mythology is that the gods are jealous
of the men because they appreciate life
Andy because they're mortal something to
lose exactly
because you know it doesn't last
forever I only want to live forever if I
got a dog that lives forever that'd be
sick right that's so much heartbreak
imagine that living forever I mean
honestly how many times can you get your
heart you focus on that first focus on
making dogs live longer that's that's to
be the they're more deserving
immortality than yeah yeah well
hopefully whatever we inject in us we
can just put in injec in our
doggies oh hold on a new Challenger
enters Lola roads says I own a vegan
bakery called chocolate and the chip how
do I get all cookies and edible cook
wait how can I get you guys cookies and
edible cookie dough first of all that's
such a cute name Lola well that too but
chocolate and the chip I oh chocolate
and the chip they're vegan um reach out
I would I want your chocolate yeah if
you make anything sweet reach out
there's a I want open door open door
open door policy on anyone making candy
we are hungry all day every
day dude I got to say food for cam these
ones were nuts did you guys agree the
balls were nuts I love it they're good
they're very good very very
good yeah dude I'm loving this now cuz
now I know which colors I like I just
immediately went for the s'mores one and
the caramel one and I just hit that so
good good memory I don't remember what
they are I feel I'm still going in blind
I feel like m
um
awesome oh
we or like full from this no let's order
right now it's 3:30 we got to do it now
let let's save this for dessert wa which
is the one that you like love it's the
three Circle one that's the smm one that
one's gone it's all gone I know okay see
none of those I like what is this one
you know what this one is the baby blue
see that's one of the ones I don't like
so it's something weird you know yeah oh
my God I don't like those I like there's
three circles and there's a brown/ red
one dark blue dark blue I don't oh
that's that one's good it's like a nou n
nougat oh that's good right yeah it is
right oh yeah you have like perfect
chocolate memory yeah I'm I'm dialed in
oh that one's like a gram cracker one oh
I love that one yeah that one's busting
all right so I love that one let's go
ahead
and get into all kinds of other fun
stuff
here this isn't the Brian Johnson show
after all it's the a rap Goda you know
what I'm saying probably get into this
Selena thing sooner than later because I
hear there's a lot to cover mhm and
we're already uh wait halfway through
the show the sandwich place doesn't
deliver here but we literally ordered
from there like I remember but last week
no problem the close one is closed to
what that was it's Friday afternoon man
what country is this I don't know why
would they close when we're live are
they close on like every
Friday you guys I I'm getting a huge by
the way oh yeah El's getting big
ah there's a baby cooking there's a baby
in there really big all right let's move
on we got a scooter video people new
scoot new scoot who's
this
oh we
SE what do you suppose the story is here
you wh what what was the what was the
plan the goal here I think I missed what
happened go ahead yeah so we're it's a
stormy day out there wherever they are
and here he is uh Captain
Ahab weathering the storm this guy
bailed when he saw him fall he's like
I'm running I think he was going to help
hell no wasn't look at him he's started
walking
away look at him he's pcing out and then
he's like hold on one more
[Laughter]
shot so what is happening I'm genuinely
wanting I mean people always stand too
close when that kind of stuff's going on
right so it's a super high tide these
look like stairs that go to the beach
usually during normal
tide
so he's on I think what is usually some
kind of walk Walking path he has a part
a scooter partner in back
potentially the floor is already wet
though you can tell the water has
reached there certainly yeah certainly
who's this in back is this another
Mobility Scooter I think that's a vesa
like a two wheel oh yeah yeah right yeah
but like also he could have could easily
taken a bigger Loop and also why did he
stop there look he stops there oh you
know rumor is he uh washed out to sea
and we haven't heard from him since just
kidding I don't know what that's not the
rumor there's no you're starting that
rumor the rumor is he was
uh washed out but no he's fine I'm sure
right yeah no yeah he survived he
survived of
course he he grew up to be Aquaman
he grew
up it's a 50-year old man I look
like um keemstar is back in the news you
guys know I love to talk about our boy
um let's see he's now doing
Boomer conservative takes about rainbows
and fortnite are apparently pissing him
off this is a wild tweet wait isn't that
a Lego set yeah it's there's a collab
now in fortnite with Lego oh okay so he
goes he goes what is this fortnite but
it's not okay it isn't fortnite no what
is this fortnite uh here it
is ah the
rainbow
ah
ah what's happening I'm turning gay my
kids are turning gay turn it off
fortnite what what are you doing what's
the agenda the Jews have clearly put
this in fortnite to turn our children
gay I'm gay I'm
gay that's the consy or what actually
I'm not the uh there's a reader note
actually I'm not there it is this is the
everyone is Awesome Lego set released in
2021 it's not even recent it's uh an
older Lego set but it's just put in
fortnite now so it was a pride month
celebration yeah I've seen that set
already a while ago what does it mean
that it's in fortnite I don't know
fortnite just has everything now but
what does that mean it just sits here in
the map like this oh someone probably
just built it they they made Lego in
fortnite oh someone just built this yeah
so it's not even fortnite no it's in
fortnite but I think it's just
previewing the new Lego there it is
collab like they just they were showing
a bunch of different like uh scenes for
the opening trailer of this of these new
modes are doing yeah well I guess so
ah we got to hit the button will
that make me
UNG no doesn't have that capability I'm
afraid keemstar is also really out there
on the
internet um Reinventing himself oh God
is this the perfect controller laughing
crying Emoji all right what do we what
is this going to do something about the
exclamation mark Emoji hold on what is
this
watch this yeah I don't think that's Kem
oh it's not some dumb Boomer nag I
thought it was like Kim and one of his
girlfriends
no
um no just a little checkin on key
dreamy key what do you want to do about
what
about there's a problem I'm just saying
it's just you've noticed this right this
has become like all every clickbait post
has to have the double red Emoji
exclamation mark there's a bunch of
accounts that do it it's part of the
language of the internet now of like I'm
being dumb and obnoxious and we don't
like it I don't like it I don't like it
I think it would help me grow problems
then people are reacting to my messages
in Discord with it right now stop stop
see it gets your get your attention
though I wanted to I like it I don't
mind it they are emphasizing this uh
food suggestion though do you want to
comment on that say what any thoughts
thoughts on food oh sure yeah I mean
what you guys said is fine men
doino button right well you don't want
Mendo it's a chain it's a chain all
righty what did you say love I said
button button you said the name of the
oh no there's a billion of them all
right yeah all right just saying just
saying just saying right I want to get
something that's not super dirty but
also tasty I do feel like it's going to
be so hard to eat their stuff on the
show uh god well it could arrive right
at the end it probably will at this rate
yeah yeah don't worry if uh it's just
this is for the uh the good old folks
who don't care about nothing I can build
a sandwich what is that I wonder what
that's
like what a concept wait that's a lot of
power hold on now they're all doing in
the chat to annoy me all right what's
well it doesn't annoy me when just like
you're just doing it in that way all
right there's there there's a there's a
sub genre of uh of post that has emerged
I'm going to make my own sandwich you
guys yeah what's the what's the fantas
the bread that's good is it a chabata it
is we love chabata chab do we want
cheese all their sandwiches are so meat
heavy they have a good uh capric
mozzarella capric I think it's called
yeah the vegan Bond me is so good yeah I
think I got to do that's what I'm
getting dude this is a weird from I'm
Waking a weird ass one here
hell yeah I'm getting the shimy shy
steak and bacon oh my God it's so
yummy with the
shibata let's see I want
cilantro
Roma are you like cilantro Roma oh I'm
doing it here that's not how it works
that's not wait I am logged into
something though I wonder if it's the
same account somebody's already doing
the order you got to just but it
consolidate for both logged in I don't
know if it's the same login that's the
question isn't it it is the question I
don't believe because usually Sam does
it but she's not here right now it's a
different account
yeah that's a shame so who's taking the
order I think Lenny is oh no we were
just talking about in chat Sam said so
here let me let me dictate this to you
and you guys say what you want you guys
can gauge this cuz this is a super
wildcard sandwich starting with shaved
roast chicken
breast okay bread choice
chabata okay bread
prep toasted that's a good one
cheese COA
cheese and a sandwich yeah okay it's
crazy do you want
accents herb ioli sure give me an accent
on that baby do they mean like sauce an
accent yeah they're being a little
snoody about it
an
accent um do would you like fruits or
veggies I want
cilantro I want pick or pickled
onions you don't like pickled onions I
would skip that one I with pickled
onions for okay then do red
onions and pickled onions that's too
much that's too much which red onions
and
spinach okay good premium
add-ons
none good that's my
sandwich doesn't sound that crazy does
it not bad I'm just considering maybe
switching the cheese but I don't know
what I'm am I taking a risk with that
but I I usually like it when it comes
what does it look like it's
like it's like a kind of a powdery one
right it's kind of crumbly yeah how I
wonder how that's going to integrate in
there
yeah we'll find out we'll find out I'm
going for it
fantastic all right very
good and that's how the ca cheese
crumbles all right where are we Kentucky
man makes $100,000 a year panhandling
and pretending to be
disabled
this man you mean Oh you mean a hustler
mhm you mean a sigma sorry that you guys
are not ready to see the truth oh
Alfredo's eating cute why that camera
for chances are seen him try to to
restaurant sympathized with his
wheelchair his drawn hands his story
they're about to turn on him they give
me money and to get some and if so
you're not alone he's dedicated he's
Faking
It America $2.4
million all that money gone now hat
actually is the truth we did some
research and sure enough Thompson's
mother was the plth in a 1993 lawsuit
against Honda for a motorcycle accident
the wreck left him with limited Mobility
but it certainly didn't make him
mentally handicapped
and we knew better he busted this bogus
beggar right outside the police
department just minutes after a press
conference about himate you guys busting
me oh he doesn't give a no he he
doesn't wow wa well he is it sounds like
he is disabled physically yeah yeah
right I don't think it's closer to to do
the other stick no the other part of
this shtick is the yeah I'm really good
at it really good I clear about $100,000
a year doing this W does he pay tax on
that I wonder yeah about 60 to 100 the
30-year-old said he's from Austin txas
when the IRS comes asking questions us
said the voice how do you report that
income I mean you got to report it it's
all cash isn't it yeah but like yeah no
I know kind a little B there's a
discrepancy in his how he lives his life
he puts it in the bank MH you know we
got we need answers here F and has done
the same thing there he also says he's
got a degree in speech language
pathology he's combined that training
with his wheelchair and found that P
using his training for Ev
hear beginning and just like that my be
boy I'm just playing I got to go y'all
got to make some money back at it again
you're crazy I got to say that
is pretty interesting I mean I guess
that's probably the best way to
respond instead of try to like run away
in the wheelchair and then having a
chase scene and all
that they got me Chase SC so he ended up
going to jail oh and yeah he ended up
related um so it says for panhandling I
mean what is pan you go to Just begging
on the
street that's jail for panhandling let
me see yeah I just see I just saw this
update right now but yeah he went to he
went to jail and then he got out I'll
find out the reason why but he he ended
up doing it again again pan handling
goes to jail all he
knows that can't be right we were
locking up panh
handlers me dude uh where does he
live what state
Kentucky Kentucky
panhandling we don't take kindly to poor
folk around here
boy
uh okay here uh charged with criminal
trespassing soliciting unlawful
compensation disorder conduct that makes
arrest unlawful compensation a hell of a
lot more sense resisting arrest jeez
what' you do
dude but I don't trust the police
the police don't trust the police how's
a dude in a wheelchair resisting arrest
give me a break that's a charge
they SLA that on our boy I mean I don't
know you've seen how like scooters could
go scooters have an engine you could you
could attempt to you could do
manslaughter in a
scooter you
know aab
brother um here is a Nook has
competition and it's you'll never guess
who it is it's Vin Diesel check it
out Vin Diesel is
competing oh that was not Vin
Vinnie the way my to car run
away is
me Nation
nationas I love that I like it wow he
has a nice rasp on his I want them to
duet MH that would be special and
Powerful babbe it's cold outside that
would be really something special W you
know a nook's probably saying this
before right Zach we might be able to do
a mashup oh has he done the
uh George Michael right I mean if it's
Christmas lated the man sung it yeah he
did it he did it Zach of course he did
can we get a mash up before the end of
the episode oh my God or Cam can do that
yeah can you send me the you want that
AB let's get him the sources here and
would you be surprised to learn that I
hate that song no way that Wham
song I'd be more surprised to find out
you likeed it what happened Dan someone
break your heart on Christmas oh my God
it's just the most annoying Christmas
song well no actually the Paul McCartney
one is worst no it's not I love that
song oh my God that is the worst he go
um he goes uh Simply Having a Wonderful
Christmas
Time hold on let me get the lyrics
that's it that's a iconic that's the
only Christmas song I like frankly I
hate that one God how you even I bro you
can't dislike PA McCartney I don't care
what I love Paul McCartney and that is
the worst song he ever made no I've
heard Christmas time the mood is right
the spirit's up we're here tonight wait
you're missing the really obnoxious 80s
80s uh
sents simply a
wonderful God I can't remember the the
the melody
yeah only
oh God it's not terrible Simply Having a
Wonderful Christmas
Time got
bounc having a wonderful Christmas time
it's fun the part's
on the feelings
here come on Dan it's Paul McCartney
with it give me chestnuts any day listen
all I got to say is we don't have any
hanuka
songss I'll there's a couple but they're
not very
Eight Crazy Nights bro everybody get
together we're going to put on Eight
Crazy Nights yeah I'll take all the
Christmas playlist we do have theava
Nagila no that's not even Hanukkah theme
though yeah all right so cam you're on
that that mashup yeah I'm downloading
them right now awesome thanks brother
that's going to be good and happy
Hanukkah to everybody oh yeah it's
yesterday started yesterday it's
actually so fun with the boys we got a
Christmas tree
we WRA presents for them it's under the
tree so it's a little hybrid just we're
doing yeah hybrid holiday uhhuh just cuz
it's fun we're just taking the fine
elements from everything yeah that's
nice and um so yesterday they opened
their first present so fun so cute and
fun nice the Christmas tradition is
pretty it rules it do so we did we did
both in my house too because of the uh I
have the split parents so yeah Mom's
family does Christmas dad's family
Hanukah so we always have both going
on yeah I mean we just light the manora
and then we go so fun I don't know the
holiday season here is so fun yeah it's
such a Vibe for sure we don't have that
in Israel definitely well here here we
actually have Smoky Robinson did a
Hanukkah
tribute I just saw that the other day oh
you've seen this yeah here Smokey go
ahead takeen
away happy Chuka I have no idea wait
wait wait Chuka is is there volume Chuka
because they said
so God bless you babe and enjoy
chanuka I was like yo Smokey you've been
on this Earth for long enough you never
heard Hanukkah ever ever Chuka like this
man's been around he's lived the life
he's not he's been in the music industry
I mean my God he certainly cross paths
with a lot of Jewish people chanuka
chanuka to be
fair that is phonetic they they don't
make it very very easy with the spelling
thing considering there's like three
official spellings of Hanukkah I agree
it's so annoying how it's done like that
because in Hebrew you say hanuka but
here you wouldn't say that so I feel
like it's easier to just say hanuka and
not even try with the ca don't attempt
the the no we don't do that no we don't
do that Hanukah people from Israel
probably think that's the way to spell
it because they're thinking hanuka right
we I would say in America we say it with
an H like yeah hanuka yeah Hana oh Chaka
o cha manora CH idea Chuka
Chuka come like the
puka anyway shout out Smokey we love
shout out Smokey Ben Shapiro's in the
house um oh is he he's reading
more uh provocative language uh
lyrics no way he's done it again why is
he doing this again he's has to be done
you think he's B yes he he mentions that
he's like for all you leftists who are
watching this m he goes hor in this
house there's some whes in this house
listen I don't I don't think it even has
to be left this Ben I mean this is just
good happy to have it for
real look at this Logan Paul and Ben
Shapiro 10 million
views Simply Having a Wonderful
Christmas Time boy look what I've done I
I I can't live with myself reading it
and I can't live with myself not reading
it so for all those who are are watching
this now on the left this is me reading
the lyrics to this is coming from your
own house brother you know what I mean
don't put this on US pound town because
it is the worst thing ever written and
it is hilariously bad and I can't stop
myself from laughing okay you ready here
we go he likes it I'm out of town my
he's pretending here's it's supposed to
be over I haven't seen the lyrics but
it's silly it's supposed to be over the
yes that's it's fun yes Ben fun you ever
heard of it dork she pink my booty hole
Brown we're now doing color descriptions
of bodily orifices okay Ben but the
booty hole is brown unless you would you
bleach your Ben not bring aess
to Brown holes yeah Brown Town rollot
Tony Brown town get yourself some more
at the
door my booger is green my ear wax
orange true but nothing rhymes with
orange that's not true Eminem taught me
porridge so Ginge
or
orange porridge I had my orange porridge
on the
[Laughter]
H where's the nword I'm looking for the
hose for the quit playing nword come
suck a
toe that's funny then indeed and he
knows it that's why it's just like he
can't even like pretend to be outraged
about yeah you know what I mean is is
trying to get the clicks well look at
the title this song has 17 million views
and I'm disturbed he wants this to be
memed exactly he's a big that was a big
hit for him when he did the cardi B
thing it's true that was epic though
he's he's become aware it's not it's not
working right well SP well said pound
town just left pound town with my n-word
he took a
down yeah that
nword a down yes why you bleeping bro
what how are we supposed to meme this
when you bleeping the good parts yeah
true yeah that N word and it just
continues along these lines what the f
and my my favorite part of this oh yeah
that nword is a really good Ben
drop is where she actually opens
applications for a stepfather for her
child that's my favorite part is where
where she like opens the resumes up it's
a social commentary dude black families
Ben oh
no uhuh I'm out here in Miami again
remember there the end of the lp has put
a travel warning on Miami for black
people so I don't even know how she's
living out down here in Florida I just
don't know I mean obviously she's the
you say the NAACP has put a travel
advisory for black people traveling to
Miami is that what he said the claim
what year is it I don't know what he's
trying me I'm going to look up what he's
talking is this the green book what's
advisory out here in Miami again
remember there the end ACP has put a
travel warning on Miami for black people
so I don't even know she's living out
what the okay here the NAACP board
of directors issued a formal travel
advisory for the State of Florida travel
advisory comes in direct response to
Governor Dan Santa's aggressive attempt
to erase black history and to restrict
diversity equity and inclusion programs
in Florida schools so it's the whole
state it's not just m Miami right I
guess that's what and I think it's just
because it's not that serious just
sounds like they're saying is a
and they're not wrong about that Ben I
hope you they're right down here in
Florida I just don't know I mean
obviously she's in serious danger in
pound town she say uhuh I'm out here in
Miami looking for the Hoochie daddies
where they at where are the NWS get that
rat all right I'm over you Ben I'm done
playing with you shut up the color of
the color of your of your booty hole
nice okay that's yo oh no Elon Ma's
upset you guys this is not
good Elon ma wow I haven't thought of
that Elon ma little freaking
while Elon
ma oh give it to you he looks pissed go
you
s
i
me
money no money no money no money oh the
Bob Iger take down oh no holy dude
wow that looked like real cash it yeah
that looks like real money uhhuh so he's
just rolling pretty
heavy no money $300 right no it's a
stack bro oh is it a whole stack look M
no looks like there's a pretty signifant
it could be fake too I don't know it's
China I don't think you can get it you
want some authentic fakes you know what
I mean some authentic fakes I heard they
s those in
uan in Jade country you're trying to
allude to yeah kind of uh well
Heron ma um J shed diss track dropped um
our boy answered the call yep I promised
him I said if you make it another diss
track I'll play it this is from uh
Jay D was it nope fella Jay fella J
fella Jay Dill is a real or that's
established person right he
fellas so he I don't know if you
know he
FAS fella wrote fellas this is what we
got going on over here down that was
beautiful we loved it yes
yes
Jesus hello what I'm saying it's not
right I've been trying to take and stuff
and I don't know it's not getting better
nothing's been helping me either maybe
you should see your
doctor we're done GG we're all getting
sick no I don't think I'm contagious
right now I'm everyone is a little bit
sick I've been like this for a week I'm
good now this past weekend I was but uh
we all I feel solid now we're just
worried about the life show curse after
last year dude I do not want to get
the power of positive thinking everyone
we're all going to be healthy we're all
going to be one of our family members
just found out they have Co oh no not in
our house but sister-in-law but we were
like we see we got to watch out for that
curse every weekend we see her so did
you see her last
weekend she got sick on Wednesday oh no
we didn't actually see them we actually
didn't that was the weekend we did not
see them went to Disney that must have
been where they got it oh that'll do it
that'll do it m all right we'll stay J
sh go ahead and and take me through this
Jay fella uh super talented musician
this guy rules Jay fella on YouTube you
know what it is let's hear
it made to the said he's tired ofing on
the news as far as you get the pick and
shoes we know you got them views from
them pretty baby blues green brown a
Hazel either way we ain't
never ever seen a monk in a pair
designer shoes you riding a lot of
weenie winning all of them stream riding
your magic carpet someone get a ma Genie
I swear I ain't racist my best friend's
from London I know how chat gets so
don't start with the assumptions J you
was cute as a button little English
muffin make me want to come over and
have some tea and Crumpet I looked
around there Ain a blemish on your name
I read life of a monk I was Hardy
entertain I hope every one of your Gucci
shirts gets a stain a through the family
you ain't with the game
yo
J don't be rigging no more stream man we
all know the real award shows the
steamies true you ain't winning that
though hell no you might H3 number one
podcast That's my
[Music]
boy there's
more call to the said he's tired of
seeing sh on the news as far as in the
views you get the pick and shoes we know
you got them views from them pretty baby
blues green brown and Hazel either way
we ain't a never ever seen a monk in a
pair designer shoes riding weenie
winning all of them stream riding your
magic carpet someone get him a genie I
swear RAC my best from London I know so
don't start with the assumtion D that
line is crazy that that was a wild
that's funny what does he mean my best
friend's from London what does that have
to do cuz that's where he's from mhm you
didn't follow Oh I thought I thought he
was referring to the Magic Carpet as
being like a racial he was yeah but then
but then he's saying he's not even he
was preemptively he's saying he's from
London so don't be but he's still
Indian well it's a that but grew up in
London yeah but magic car isn't even
Indian anyways
so right it's Persian uh yeah yeah or
Arabian I mean it's from Arabian nights
so I guess Arabian but it's it's I was
just like y any it's not Indian the
point this dude's he's got his uh the
the defense for himself already in there
for the song
b here way it's just looping it's just
looping yeah that shout out to J fella
for that we love it I think it's also uh
important context to mention that you
asked for this on Monday and this was
premiered on Monday he made on Monday
what yeah holy he was on
it that's nuts dude well there it is
everyone go check out J Shetty Dis Track
by your boy Jay
fella
fellas
um looking if there's anything else real
fast at the top I guess not so we're
we're looking good for Selena we are
clear to go for Selena we're ready for
launch yeah let's get educated are you
ready Olivia yeah you ready we're with
you Olivia to the end thanks everybody
thanks everybody so I'm somewhat aware
of uh this I saw some drama of it
floating around mhm Selena started has a
new boyfriend yes Benny Blanco right yes
and actually
interestingly I know him
because I follow him on Tik Tok cuz he's
he's actually pretty funny mhm yeah and
he makes these videos where he shits on
um Charlie poth Charlie poth that I like
oh they're besties yeah I think they're
just playful which interesting because
Selena and Charlie also have a p but now
uh now uh he is he looks just like a
he's Jewish I'm assuming right I
actually didn't do my research on that
part he is he's just you know what I did
see that he was Jewish when I looked him
up the other day he's like the
most ass scruffy little Jewish
looking dude you can ever imagine um
he's Jewish native of Northern
Virginia but he pulled Selena I he is a
mega Talent though and very successful
very successful and very funny yes so
with that being said Selena baby bite
your tongue challenge go ahead Olivia so
what's the problem this all sounds great
so far all right yeah well we'll see
we'll get into it so miss Selena baby
bite your tongue and you're you're a
Selena you're a
Gomez a selenator A selenator I truly
for my whole life have admired her there
there's one specific slide in here that
I'm like oh I don't know if I can I
don't like what she said um so we'll get
to that I think that cringe isn't
illegal but like it's on sometimes it's
Unbecoming oh for well yes yes and so
I'm just I don't know I don't I don't
love what I'm seeing okay well let's see
she's she's Making Waves here people are
not happy here's
Selena lupus Queen we love her lupus
Queen she's an inspiration to all of us
she actually queen that is true
entrepreneur too right she has a
successful makeup line rare Beauty yes
who also stole my sound by the way like
super successful right successful is
like underselling it isn't it like crazy
massive yes she is she hit billionaire
status oh oh yeah oh she
should be able to with that kind she did
this year
who wow so players Selena Gomez we know
who she is Benny Blanco these are some
of his star studded songs uh the amount
of hits he's done with the breath of uh
artist is nuts what do you mean he makes
songs I wasn't following a producer okay
got you you know how does for
Austin he's The Music Man Okay cool so
and then another player in this is
Selena Gomez Brazil 2.0 this is where
all of the comments took place no don't
with the Brazil fan account
literally Justin Bieber we know who he
is he's it's a wild look it is a wild
look his wife looked stunning that day
she wore that when she wore like a
gorgeous glammed up look for a launch
yeah for her
was he trying to do like the Kanye thing
where he just is down although this is
quite an attention grabbing look I have
to say where Kanye was very like muted
yeah like you weree all black to the m
Gallow Kim just Dickies or something
right um another player us the innocent
bystanders who have
to deal with all of this
now the victim and all wow the we the
real victims the real victims us where
is David in all this for real yeah what
does David think so a quick Spark Notes
on Selena Gomez Benny Blanco
relationship same old love was produced
by Benny Blanco in 2015 that's a song
about Justin Bieber um wow it was a
really really great song he did a
wonderful job 2019 they did a collab
called I can't get enough that was also
I mean that one wasn't as successful as
the first but still they collabed
together they knew each other and then
2020 one year later he collabed with
Justin Bieber and they put out this song
called lonely and it was like a big deal
for him it was it was shift in his
career it was during the pandemic it was
after he got married Justin or Benny
Justin okay yeah this was like Justin's
story of growing up and feeling lonely
and being like a child star dude these
people go to him like for important
like when it comes to music yeah so
during promo for that the next slide
this was a big deal I remember watching
it being like you Benny Blanco
because he was doing promo for the
Justin song and someone asked him like
why do you love Justin Bieber so much
and Selena had just dropped her makeup
line like maybe a week prior and if you
click watch this is what he said
interesting a lot of changes in three
years hey Benny boy hey Benny your
walls get out look Justin's not one of
those like Cookie Cutter pop artist like
you know they're like this is my new
single and here's my makeup line and
he's like like Justin's like yo uh I
have a pimple and I have anxiety today
so first and for so down to earth Lally
um it just felt unnecessary that's it
she had just dropped her makeup line but
and just I mean do we know that it's not
about her cuz there's a million people
dropping makeup lines that's a St at the
time it was Rihanna Selena that's it
that's yeah and Rihanna hadn't made
music since not a lot not a
lot there were two he's like like J's
those those were the those were like the
two big pop stars that had done makeup
lines so I mean yeah it's indirectly
referring to her and they were broken up
at this time Olivia oh yeah they they
did not like each other and she had come
out with lose you to love me like they
were against they were not friends let
me listen again here's my makeup line
and he's like know they're like and
Selena's been like criticized for being
cookie cutter because I
mean she's a Disney in a good way she
yeah she is not one of those like cook
cutter pop artist like you know they're
like this is my new single and here's my
makeup line well hold on what's cookie
cutter about that especially there was
only two with makeup lines I don't
understand the criticism maybe he's like
insinuating a cash grab or something
Benny okay that does seem like a weird
like I looked listen I'm not guy's very
successful obviously knows what he's
doing I looked at his like list all he
does is work with cookie cutter pop
artists so but
justed come on just is not one of those
come on now but if you're talking to him
if you're talking about Justin and
you're saying someone with a makeup line
everyone's going to assume that it's
Selena he should be aware of that yeah
all right shame on you Benny you
monster so no uh cookies for you okay
all right so now people have noticed
that Benny's getting into the cooking
game he just dropped a cooking book
Selena has her inFAMOUS or her famous
Selena and Chef show I actually just
learned that Infamous is negatively
charged
that I didn't know I'm so sorry if I
ever called you Infamous I just thought
I meant famous um notorious Sor you had
to put that in well but it's in famous
yes now I've I've put it together and I
understand and I will never make the
mistake again well hold on notorious has
a negative connotation Infamous I think
is mostly negative but it can be also
neutral I believe Infamous then her
Infamous show Selena and Chef I mean
it's a it's a little it's got a little
taste of something but I do think you
can use it not according to Mariam
Websters my friend having a reputation
of the worst kind is Infamous well
that's a hold on let's see Wicked
abominable that's not good it sounded
pretty bad I I think in uh recent times
you're right like people kind of
jokingly the infamous so and so or
whatever um using it kind of like a
poking fun at somebody way okay there it
is in Miss so okay they're both
cooking yes so yeah she commented people
were like oh I think something's Brewing
here she's in his comments he's doing
cooking and it turned out that we
were we were all correct H just based on
that one comment though no that she she
had been liking his he was liking
her they followed each other
Selena's mom followed him on in there
was a lot of clues that I saw in the
Selena
okay Twitter okay interesting so I saw
this on Twitter I thought it was funny
meet Selena's opponent a brick wall um
because once they announced that they
were dating if you go to the next slide
she was all over Instagram someone
posted she just came out with her
Christmas edition of Selena and Chef and
she said that she had a crush on someone
in the show so someone posted I hope
that um things went well with her crush
and she was like yay it did which let
everyone know okay she's about to
announce a relationship which she did
what am I reading here what Selena Gomez
commented on my post so this is the
Brazil one no the next one is the Brazil
one but she's commenting on fan accounts
that's kind of weird I it is cringe like
I wouldn't well I don't know how many
fan accounts I have but like I wouldn't
I wouldn't interact like that yeah espe
but she's like number one Superstar
which is why I am surprised that she
does that so and then she responded too
so she's in the the thread I Love You
Queen I hope you're happy hi Queen We
love you thank you the happiest I've
ever been she said mhm
wow then pop factions posts uh Selena
Gomez is rumored to be dating producer
Benny Blanco she likes it she comments
facts which I think is so
cringe
facts that's what she she didn't post a
photo with him yet she just commented on
pop factions facts that's pretty it's
like so Millennial I'm going to die how
old is she 31 oh she's pushing it we're
a bit old yeah interesting okay in a
beautiful young and glowing way just for
Instagram comments yes yes yeah
so this is where Selena Gomez Brazil 2.0
Selena this fan comment or this fan post
just posts about the fact that she
confirms it and she comments he is
absolute everything in my heart which
then obviously opened a conversation in
the comments with all of her fans and
she
participated in fighting with them
pretty much okay but so she what are
they fighting about he they it just they
just don't like him why don't they like
him they think she's responding to
comments that say like he's so ugly girl
like she's choosing the like really
cringe comments to respond to it's just
weird he's so ugly but that's not that's
just some weird Internet troll just the
internet right that can't be like a
serious criticism of of the guy I mean
obviously she says he is my absolute
everything in my heart so she is riding
for her
man but then this is when it goes off
the reals yeah so she goes he is
absolutely everything in my heart then
why is he the just someone said
something about him and she says then
why is he the best thing that's ever
happened to me the end and then she goes
yeah he's still better than anyone I've
ever been with facts which is like why
are we talking about our ex's publicly
so childish in this comments yeah it
just it feels like she should not be
participating in this she goes I don't
understand if you actually care about me
this is my happiest if you don't feel
free to say whatever you want but I will
never allow your words to guide my life
ever I'm done if you can't accept me at
my happiness then don't be in my life at
all okay hold on I have no problem with
anything she said I agree with those
sentiments for sure I mean the fact that
she's arguing with like it's just cringe
small fan accounts is is something she
shouldn't do but like she hasn't said
anything even mean she's just saying I
like him and that's it really all there
is to us I I mean certainly wouldn't
recommend arguing with fan accounts
though that that's definitely not a path
to mental
Wellness
okay then someone commented the exact
same thing that she commented on Justin
Bieber's Post in um 2016 he was dating
Sophia Richie at the time who was
underage and he was overage so there
there are different nuances going on but
she responded to the exact same words
that she responded to him where she was
like don't be mad at your fans they love
you stop posting if you don't want
people to say things about it okay so
hold on she left this comment on his
post she said if you can't handle the
hate then stop posting pictures of your
girlfriend it should be special between
you two only don't be mad at your fans
they love you interesting and somebody
cleverly uh copy pasted
that in her comments
and she didn't realize right she said
not mad it's been six months baby which
I'm so happy for her she's in a
relationship for six months that's
amazing I will always defend my friends
and family and fans till the day I die
okay hold on um I mean again she doesn't
realize why is she responding to one
what is yeah that's the main question
here is like why concerned about her
like why be busy in the comments like I
do hope she's okay if like this isn't
something that she normally does does
she used to like 10 years ago she used
to participate in like Instagram
comments but she took a long break I
just hope that she's okay I don't think
this is a symptom of some I think mental
unwellness because she has been
diagnosed with bipolar uh that's tough
definitely
um but yeah I mean she didn't realize
that this guy was but again her response
isn't bad at all she's just being she's
being fine totally fine but again she
looks a little silly cuz yeah she didn't
realize you can go you you go ahead oh
this one I thought was really funny no
why Selena you are so gorgeous what the
hell and she just goes I am gorgeous I'm
normal which I love two likes what is
she doing how many comments is she
reading she really she did she she's
inep she went in she's inde deep
somebody screenshotted this 9 seconds
after it was left how cuz she was just
in there
commenting commenting commenting people
were just watching the show nine
seconds though
Jesus
um this criticism I mean I understand
being like so annoyed by that like oh
he's not he's not good looking enough
for you but girl you're 31 let's not
let's stay off Instagram and 31 is Young
just stay just the comments it feels
juvenile mhm I mean old enough to know
not to argue with people in the comments
that's just what I mean
yeah um her choice and men someone said
with the flat face L well everyone did
suck it's unnecessary but who cares she
doesn't like her exes it's not a big
deal who's she insulting somebody that
she's made up with she's insulting
Justin Bieber well she doesn't like him
that's well known she's allowed to do
that right I guess she yeah yeah she's
she's fine to say Justin sucks it's no
problem yeah I mean Justin does suck he
does suck yeah he seems like a giant
douchebag get her out of my shot get her
out of my shot get her out of my shot
Ian don't play her like that Ian do you
want to fight on cam cuz we can you're
causing problems in her real life know
what that was some weird glitch I don't
know what happened right right right
ghost in the machine watch yourself I'm
normal is pretty funny though yeah I
think that's hilarious I'm normal what
is that okay no idea what that even
means I'm normal I'm one of
you
okay all
right uh continuing she said oh
sweetheart I've been in therapy since I
was 18 I know what's best for me and I
will fight till I get what I deserve I
appreciate your misguided input but I'm
growing don't feel free to grow with me
just know I'm never going to be with a
boy ever again sorry to disappoint
just like calling I I just when you're
when you're excited about a new
relationship I just think it's weird to
talk about all of your other ones also I
I don't know anything about Benny Benny
boy but it looks a little a little bit
like a boy like a boy you
think I don't think so he's he's a weird
creative goofball okay I don't know
anything about he's a he's a goofball
just based on the few pictures I've seen
I'm keeping my eye on it I think that
the fact that he said something that was
possibly like shading her in the past
it's like you better treat her
incredibly cuz that's but
um the problem is like she's 31 as we
said if she's these people arguing in
the comments of these fan accounts are
probably kids frankly I mean there's a
good chance she's arguing with a
12-year-old or a 15-year-old and like if
you were 18 even but still she's
probably younger though yeah there's a
good chance and like if you were in the
room with the 16-year-old would you even
care or like respond to this
dumb you'd be like no you're 16 you
don't know
anything buddy I'm 16 I think this is
coming off of the backlash you got for
the situation and the the Middle East
like I feel like it got her nerves a
little bit on the edge and this just
happened to be the perfect storm I don't
know what's that what's that context is
that in here um the the like nail in the
coffin for it basically a few weeks ago
she was very wishy-washy and like would
not stand with anybody really she was
just like I love my little sister it's
really hard to like see that people are
dying and like that kids are who her
little sister she has her own little
sister she just like used it as like I
have so much love in my heart I can't IM
IM what it's like to like lose someone
like and problema people wanted her to
comment on the situation and she gave a
very political PR answer of like I love
everyone pulled up I want to see it I
want to see it she was like I'm getting
offline I love everybody someone said
why are you acting like 31's elderly I'm
not it's just that's a age where you
have matured mature I call her old she's
she's she should be a matured a human
being at 31 her brain should be there
you know those kind of comments seem
kind of juvenile so I don't know what's
the context of this whole thing but I
did see that she was getting heat for it
yeah she said like a post I'm I'm
getting it for you she said a post won't
change anything and it's like but you're
the most followed person on
Instagram blows my mind she's number one
not that she isn't the bigest celebrity
but godamn number like legitimately the
biggest account on Instagram hands down
is her yeah so I guess people were
asking her to make a statement cuz I
mean everybody everyone was asking
everyone at the time to do that so she
responded this was a response I've been
taking a break from social media because
my heart breaks to see all the horror
hate violence and Terror that's going on
people being tortured and killed or any
Act of hate towards any one group is
horrific when you prct all people
especially children and stop the
violence for good sorry if my words will
never be enough for everyone or hashtag
I just can't stand innocent people
getting hurt that's what makes me sick I
wish I could change the world but a post
won't so listen I have no problem with
with this this girl she's if you're in a
sensitive state of mind and she is the
number one most followed whatever you
say Pro or against you will get
crucified you will get hated and
passionately hated by the most psychotic
people on the internet so I don't
think that she owes anybody to
say a goddamn do you know what I mean
like person why do you need well who
gives a what Selena Gomez thinks
she science I agree that what the
does she know about going to do anything
like let's have some humility let's like
like not every buddy it needs to
H not everyone has an informed good
opinion and knowing the limit of your
knowledge on it is commendable
like you don't need to go out there and
say a damn thing when there was the
black lives matter and people posted
black squares people were made fun of
for that because it's like yeah you're
just an influencer and a stupid post is
not going to change anything well it
depends what what you're posting like if
if you're posting a black square and
there's nothing to make a thoughtful
post you need to be know you need to
know what you're talking about influence
yeah the influence to do what to do to
make a stand one way or another but you
need to know what you're talking about
to make a thoughtful post right and I I
think maybe she should have said that
yeah what do you mean she would have got
the same amount of she would have
got the same amount of she would
have better off just saying nothing man
because this is going to piss people off
too and it did but like she we don't
need everyone's opinion okay
godamn you know what is uh what's the
line that uh Chappelle J Rule oh yeah
what is J Rule did do we know what Ja
Rule thinks about Israel Palestine you
know like we don't need to know what
Selena Gomez thinks and yes she's the
most followed person on Instagram I not
for her political views for her music
and for her makeup I guess I don't know
makeup now in the totality of the world
where everybody's talking about this and
thinking about it I really don't think
that her saying what did you want her to
say that what what was it that that she
should have said they wanted her to take
a stand like like I mean people are
going to get mad either way but either
say that she's in support of of
Palestine or or Israel whatever whoever
she's in support of and they want her to
shoot her career into the ground because
once you take a stand the one of the
side is going to want to kill you do
people literally so ruthless about this
topic people are like they are
obsessed with the idea that now I'm a
Zionist and I hate Palestine like I'm as
bad as Ben gavier on on a
netanyahu's war cabinet like they their
people do not make nuanced takes on this
at least a lot of them so in my opinion
I mean she's she's like listen the I
don't want innocent people to get her
what what what more do you want and I
mean you
know it's just I don't know at what
point the war was when this happened
either because that kind of yeah it was
a few weeks after right yeah everything
kicked
off I don't know it seems it seems silly
to get mad at her for not saying it's it
seems unfair but I think that then she
shouldn't have said anything at all
because then why are you adding to a sea
of saying nothing but to me it's like
she didn't try to say anything bad here
she's just saying it's hurting her heart
to see what's happening and that's just
the human response it every nobody right
now is happy to see what's happening
right and then she followed that though
because people there was a little bit of
there was like mild outrage from that
and she responded with I sent it in chat
okay so it made it oh she responded yeah
she did a second story where she decided
she's taking a break from Instagram
she's done she doesn't support any of
what's going on it's just like you made
this why are you the victim now like
well hold on I don't know I felt like
this is not I don't think this is a fair
criticism of Her Like She's the victim I
mean she didn't do anything but this
this Instagram story is so dramatic so
she says I'm taking a break and deleting
my Instagram I'm done I do not support
any W yeah because she's probably being
told by people that you're genocidal
Zionist a pig you're a Nazi and like
didn't choose a side she was probably
already getting so much for saying
the most basic comment ever just that
you're hating to see what's happening
that's apparently not okay these days
you can't say a statement like that
which is crazy to me she she's in a
sensitive mental state probably and she
doesn't want to deal with this so
when she get says something like I you
know I hate to see and by the way I know
what she means cuz when I'm online and
like especially when this was all
happening there were so many horrific
disturbing images of everything on both
happening in Gaza that happened on in in
Israel and it was really really um
depressing and
disturbing to see it all and like I
totally understand her desire for to
wanting to take a break from seeing that
I mean she's you know and
so if she be she's being called a Nazi
and a Zionist and a freak and
all the worst things you can imagine you
know I understand her being upset and
saying it I'm out of here and she
by the way what she said it was a little
dramatic but it wasn't like mean she
wasn't being mean to anybody she was
being a little dramatic I agree I like
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt you go
ahead no I just going to say like yeah I
can only imagine the stress she's going
through because even at a small level
you know of course Ethan you've gone
through it and also like me and Lena
like on one end like seeing these videos
I've never seen Lena like just cry
randomly and this has been happening for
the past few months just watching videos
because because we're from Dearborn all
of our friends and family are posting
what's going on in Palestine and
overseas and it's tough and then at the
same time we're being harassed on every
platform for not speaking about it and I
don't know it's a it's a weird conflict
in my head because there is a level of
disappointment and not speaking on it in
myself um but also it's like it's just
it's a lot it's a lot and it's like this
mind game that you're constantly playing
dude you're not you're not a
elected official you're not a political
you know you you're under no obligation
bro I'm finding myself having this
conversation with my mom even cuz she's
like out of worry for me cuz I've been
going through it too and she's like um
don't say anything don't comment you
you're just going to make yourself a
Target she's actually worried about me
like something happening to me if I say
something and then at the same time we
were talking about it and she's like
yeah I mean on the other hand you do
want to say something right cuz you feel
like I don't know
it's crazy and you want to say something
it's it's really complicated but I'm not
educated enough to say something worthy
of of this kind of attention not for me
what do you want to say like that Israel
I didn't study politics or the history
or I'm not educated enough to make a a
real well listen what do they want you
don't need to be educated say this
horrible uh massive loss of civilian
life in Gaza is horrible and it's tragic
and it's but but that's not enough but
like is that what you wanted she didn't
say that but she she said I hate that
everyone died on all the in she she did
in a way she said seeing
[Music]
innocent
I don't want deal with
yeah that is what I believe though but
like um by the way I'm sorry that you
guys are going no it's not it's not your
no I mean I just feel Sor I know exactly
what you mean I be because I'm like it's
it's like every day in my head like
should I say something am I letting
somebody down by not saying something
but who am I to say something I don't
know anything about I don't know nothing
about nobody and there's there's another
aspect to it in our situation
specifically um you know of course we
love you guys and you guys being from
Israel it's like anything we do say
they're going to somehow weaponize it
against you guys like in one way or
another they're going to or someone else
or the rest of the crew members ignoring
you guys if we say something and and
they don't say nothing then they're
going to be like oh what when are they
going to speak up like these they're
being harassed and they're not even Arab
like they they're getting comments all
the time well and people do you I've
seen lots of people being like how can
Lena and ab stand while Ethan sits there
and says this which again I don't
know what I said but uh and being do
that already being able to like be
friends with you guys here and leave
here and like have this like conflict be
taken away from the situation has been
such a beautiful experience for me but
like I there's no way to talk about this
without sound stupid or ignorant or
whatever and like we have this privilege
of being here and the conflict is taken
out of the situation and we're we love
each other here like family yeah I I
don't know what is there to say to make
somebody happy I don't even know what
I'm trying to say honestly well so like
I was saying is that like you don't need
to be informed on anything to say the
loss of life in Gaza is horrific there's
there is and it is horrific the amount
of Civilian death happening there is
tragic and awful and terrible
and
uh saying that so but but that's say
that
alone will get the Israeli side like
pissed at you cuz you're not saying that
there somebody something happened
there yeah you would you would probably
have some people being like well what
about happen here everybody wants to get
recognition for the they're dealing
with both sides want it I think the the
thing that H and it's by the way sorry
it's not a measurement of who's getting
it wor both sides see themselves as the
victims objectively you know Gaza is
getting absolutely crushed on a
scale that's
absurdly uh disproportionate like that's
obvious right so that's worth being said
because before people run away
with anything I'm trying to say go sorry
Olivia go ahead um no no no you're okay
I think just the the vagueness in her
post and the fact that like she's
posting on the most influential account
ever and she ends it with like a post
won't change anything when she could
have linked some sort of fundraiser she
could have linked a source to
information like she has people on her
team that could help inform her about
like ways that she can go about this
with what she believes if she want I
just feel like solid like I don't think
she knows what she believes it seems
like I honestly disagree I disagree well
like I I know what you're saying right
you she could have a big impact if she
was like yo support this I support these
people and here's how you can support
them but I think the what I'm getting
from her is that she doesn't really
she's not confident in pointing people
one way or another because she doesn't
really know then I think she shouldn't
have said anything yeah I agree she
shouldn't have said think now she
probably learned her lesson I'm sure
she's not going to say anything about it
again no actually go to the next slide
because this is what like actually
pissed me off is someone in her comments
was like you'll be quiet about all of
like people are asking you to talk about
this and you're not talking about it but
you'll like go to bat and like talk to
your fans and fight with them in the
comments about your boyfriend and she
just responded with you're right and
then continued posting about him I'm
trying to find the slide where the
did it
go did I close it okay hold on let me
open it again and and this is just
what's going on online like we got to
deal with it in real life too Lena got
in an accident like a month ago minor
accident in a parking lot and she got
called a Arab or what what
you he asked me if I'm Palestinian I
said no he's like well what are you I
said Lebanese and he's like yeah you're
all the EP and same what a piece
of I love how he had to ask he's
like are you this one are you this one
are you this one okay yeah you're all
the same it's like what the bro
doesn't make any sense that's disgusting
what' he look like what kind of dude was
it he looked like a Dum
weirdo weirdo dumbass idiot he's really
me old white guy no he was uh what
what we know what national I think think
well he was speaking Spanish okay but my
uh oh Wild Card my uh yeah Wild Card
racist we love it
yeah my barber who speaks Spanish came
out to defend Lena he recognized her hey
yeah a legend yeah yeah I'm sorry but
that's horrible yeah what the but
obviously you know like Ela was saying I
love you guys like there's not and and
by the way I
mean okay whatever it's not you know
off if you're going to be a little
weird freak about it we're all it is
what it is and it ain't what it ain't
you know what I mean um where were
we but yes I love you guys the respon
that actually pissed me off and you know
you can always talk to me about
something yeah no I know and and just
everyone knows Ethan's always given us a
platform he's never ever try to silence
anything we say he's always allowed us
to speak if we want so yeah and I hope
that you guys feel comfortable reaching
out to me privately anytime of course
yeah it is what it is it is what it is
okay
so let's go where were
we okay where were we uh go back to nail
on the coffin okay so we're caught up on
the on the uh that people who are so
there was like a lot of anger to her at
this point there was okay but I feel
like most of it came from after she
announced her break because people were
like why is why are you being so
dramatic right now well another thing
I'm seeing is like
yeah people say they go with every all
these civilians dying and you're you're
making yourself the victim although
again I think that's a kind of a
dramatic assessment she just wanted to
step away from the internet she
didn't say she's a victim she I do too
but then why why make a spectacle of
your of your departure why not just she
tried and she failed what I can try to
speculate I don't know what happened I
feel like she probably got so much
for what seemed like the most basic
human comment M that it made her so
frustrated and she was like I'm done
with the internet you guys suck yeah
that's that's how I translate it listen
at the end of the day she's a human
being she has you know what I mean she
she's like the most popular person on
Instagram and you want her to act like
royalty and you want her to act like a
perfectly groomed princess who's ready
to take over but like she's just a
person right I wasn't outraged
by that I was annoyed by for sure I was
very
upset with her comment so let's go to
the next one uh her choice in men LOL
everyone did suck oh sweet we read this
one yeah and this one okay you want to
you want to read it yeah so she said
she's out here doing the absolute most
under this post over some ass
relationship but when asked to speak
with but asked to stand with the people
of Palestine all of a sudden she has to
take a social media break oh call drops
and she just goes you're right that was
not a good response right why' you do
why why and then she continues I
included her Instagram stories too she
continues posting about her new
boyfriend like and and memes of her
Disney Channel like show so it's it's
not that she's saying you're right
you're actually you are correct and
she's stepping away like she one more
time let me being sarcastic yeah I think
this is mean yeah she's yeah yeah she's
being sarcastic she's at her doing the
absolute most under this post over some
ass relationship about when talk
has to stand with people of Palestine
all of a sudden she had to take a social
media
Break
um yeah you're right okay yeah that was
super unnecessary it's up I mean
she's she's getting a little
like yeah she needs to close her phone
I've been there I know what she's going
through I've been there it's when you
you lose your mind on social
media sometimes yeah and you're just
like you're you're just up and
you know it yeah uh uh she said never
trolling I'm leaving insta for a while
until I have work again what does that
mean she she can work she Dro singles
and has but she she broke the break an
hour later oh she's back she started
posting on her story again no she's
doing the quartering leaving
Twitter um I just stand up for what I
believe in I have no shame in doing that
I love my fans more than anything in the
world okay I mean again it's just a
weird non statement m MH yeah also
saying I stand up for what I believe in
like do you is weird because the
accusation is that yeah that she didn't
make a sense and yeah so so it's just a
little bit like I guess yeah missing the
criticism or not caring about I don't
know so these were her stories from
yesterday um she posted the one on the
right is like her hard
launch pick and then after all of her
comments she she posted just a reminder
how much I appreciate and love every one
of you that was after all the fighting
mhm and then if you go to the next one
yeah but ultimately she didn't say
anything terrible so like you know for
on her end I understand her being like
what what is happening right now like
I'm being like can cancelled quote
unquote like super harshly and I mean
you know I understand where she's I
guess coming from to an
extent her in stories were wild
continued uh she's posting Rings The
Wizard of wavery Place
bloopers so what is wild about these it
was just like she doesn't normally post
this constantly and she was fighting
with her fan she was just very active on
social media and like said she was going
to take a break and then came back and
posted a photo or like bloopers of
wizards and then her new ring it's like
she's never this this giving right it's
possible that she is going through
something I mean
if I think I think something's I hope
that she's okay this certainly could be
like a manic thing I don't know you
know um and certainly there are triggers
for episodes too which yeah being called
a Nazi by a bunch of of your
fans is probably pretty
upsetting and then the next one is oh
look it's a B for be quiet Benny got her
that was just that was a little your
commentary yeah um B is Benny she got a
ring
people I also thought this Justin got
her a ring like a very famous ring that
everyone still talks about to this day
with a J and she posted about it then
Haley got a j tattoo with a star Selena
then got a star on her finger and now
she's posting with a B so people are
just like I need an initial and it
the next the next slide is last one I
need some with the H from you
quick the next slide's the last one it
uh it's from Sheen people found it no oh
is it was this a joke no they probably
made that after heed yeah wait hold the
phone that's their whole thing right is
like ripping off yeah it is all over
Twitter that people are like d there's
no way he bought her a
$10 I mean there's no way those are real
diamonds he's Rich As I know that's
why people are like let's talk about it
then why would Sheen make a be they
ripped that off they ripped it off for
people to buy it for $10 that's crazy
though how fast they work they do work
fast that has to be it that's crazy
though Sheen is making them all look bad
man they're up we got to sue
Sheen for defamation or something oh
they have like a million lawsuits really
yeah awesome because they steal
everything they steal like with no shame
I wonder if they are making enough money
to survive I think they do the massive
lawsuit you should look up how big they
are I think the owner is a billionaire
they're like one of the biggest
companies that means what is their
margin cuz their stuff is so cheap like
how do they do it man
Sheen uh valuation 2022 100 billion more
than H&M and Zara combined what the
more than H&M and Zara combin Sheen
reportedly seeking a 90 billion
valuation in IPO okay well they're
seeking yeah it's
scary 90 billion
holy yeah you can pay off all those
settlements okay interesting commentary
here you want to break this
down I can do it oh we don't like this
we're skipping this part getting out of
it so that's that's it that is it okay
okay man so are we happy for the
relationship part if she is happy I am
so
said she is she says that she is I hope
that she's okay I really hope that she's
okay I think she should stop fighting
with fans in the comments yeah sure I'm
happy or sad or whatever it
is yeah I support you I'm not reading
all that but than all that um do you
guys want a pallet cleanser I got I
finished the Nook yeah I want a yes
yes are those where are those sandwiches
by the way cuz we I have to like leav in
oh uh I'll look into it we're going to
be here 50
450 450 oh that's 10 minutes okay we're
probably have to take it to go though
you
mhm this is it you guys the mashup of
the Season Christmas music everybody's
buzzing about this
anok uh collaboration it's huge
hello
Christmas Lord chrristmas I give you my
heart
and the way my
[Music]
to to carry my the very next day you
give
way to S me f I give it to someone
special
[Music]
I love that that's
beautiful oh he's sicking around oh love
that about him just stay he just doesn't
go
anywhere gorgeous M he doing an idol
animation man you to
default there he is hello he's got the
Christmas spirit in
him that was good that was special that
was wonderful thank you cim yep Merry
Christmas
yeah let's check out some of of the
donies Laura said I've got a Flem cough
for 2 months and nothing helps we do
have an inhaler now which helps
sometimes really they couldn't find a
cause for it oh Jesus it's like
super flemy it's
horrible message your
doctor I know it's like when I once I
message my doctor it starts this whole
chain reaction of I don't want
to do so here's 10,000 blood tests you
need to do
exactly like I appreciate how thorough
they are but like I don't know it's just
not I don't know if it's that serious
[Music]
yet transformative says
um just came back from Midwest furfest
Ela was seeing the furry family wearing
a lot of Teddy fresh really oh man we
love our fur family out furry family I
love the fur we're
rooing you know
why was it um Andrew Callahan that we
talked about Furon with yeah because he
actually brought a perspective that made
me see them differently he really
humanized them in a way that I thought
was really helpful right I remember that
yeah just like there that the community
seems really nice and wholesome and uh
good for for them uh sansar says five
gifted subbies thank you
Legend sansar says I'm back thanks Dan
what does that mean you B them or
something no uh they were having some uh
they were having like a weird glitch on
YouTube and I helped them help them out
thank you for that jenerous and and the
glitch was that they couldn't donate and
so then they uh thanked Us by donating a
big thanks thank you zanar we love about
you thank you Pika pumpy pumy hi Ethan
can you please give a shout out to Megan
Jalil and Boris we're Australian so if
you want to say it in our native
language you can say good day m how you
going how you going n I'll say like this
um hey Megan n
ner good day mate how you going good day
Megan Good Day having a barie how you
going good day Megan having a Barbie
with
Boris turned him
gay I would die to go to
Australia I got we can make it happen we
literally cannot
yeah that's true have to wait a while we
have to wait like 10 years before we can
take any Australia's pretty serious too
that's a long ass flight that's like as
far a long as a flight as you can take
pretty much one of the longest at least
from from La you can take I went and
stayed with exchange students in
Australia I was in eighth grade yeah
they stayed with me when I was in
seventh grade did you love it I loved it
did you guys have a Barbie yeah we had a
few Barbies bobes did you eat any bush
meat did I eat any uh bush meat yeah
zesty delicious bush
meat dysphoria
backlash fig
Fire come to Australia I will in about
like 10 years when the kids grow up yeah
Emily says the blue dude is blue because
of how deeply inbred he is there's a
whole family look up blue people of
Kentucky I'm on it that's sick hold on
blue people of
Kentucky
[Music]
I'm in when that song came out they were
so stoked they're like yo that's for
that's speaking my heart I'm
blue I found a uh this is just an
illustration there's a Wikipedia article
about it uh wait why are we back on this
fugazi some donated said he's
inbr blue Fugazi
I don't see any other images than this
guy he's the only one that made it out
from the forest from the
for this one looks edited that can't be
real no it's real he looks like that but
why does it look cuz here it looks
totally different maybe it's the studio
the lighting lighting and stuff cuz this
is straight Smurf it's lighting
that's what people call him as Pap Smurf
I sent a photo Let's see we love it
about them though oh here they are this
this is the rumor the fabled uh silver
consuming
tribe the
aboriginals they're
blue there a special bunch of people oh
my Lord I wish I was
blue you you weren't here for this is
this before you came out get we to make
you an avatar got to make you blue dude
we got blue you you got watch the way
water dude you better do an avar episode
I'd love that yeah I love dressing up
that was so fun we got to do that again
were we just wear avatar for no reason
you didn't even know we were doing it
wasn't for no reason it wasn't for no
reason well cuz you guys were trying to
get me to watch that dumbass movie
didn't work didn't work suckers the
movie of the year dude lost bro I did
love it not the movie The bit I haven't
seen the movie yeah I refus to same here
funky Miss wimpy says Hey crew I despise
being this person but I have to ask you
for help covering hospital
bill
[Music]
button okay how much how much are we
talking I don't want to do this I'm
sorry funky I love you but I don't want
to do this charge back get the $10 back
please true charge back
YouTube um I don't know what to say it's
just it
gets it gets touchy I made it I said I
would stop doing that but I want to
support people in other ways that is
more organized and official whatever
that
means but
um I mean listen how much are we talking
about here you you should need to tell
me are we talking about 500 we talking
about th000 or you going to send me a
bill for, you never know that's what I'm
saying the fact that she doesn't say the
numbers concerning to me cuz I I don't
want to be like yeah I'll help you out
and then she sends us like a $15,000
Voice who sent the donation take it from
their
salary true who sent that me that's
being thought no I'm kidding I did give
I said listen I explicitly did give you
instructions to put every donation there
yeah and that thank you I had I was
planning on not sending it but then no
you you did good I want to acknowledge
everyone Jennifer needs help with our
wedding the duct from
El funky Miss wimpy message one of the
mods and send me the invoice I'm not
making any guarantees to you at all I'm
not even saying I'm going to do anything
for you I just want to see the Bill
thank you funky Miss wimpy you guys got
that 5,000 dongar it's 2.5k how do you
know they just said it oh they already
said it she said it's 2.5k I know I'm so
sorry send the
bills and nobody do this anymore what is
what are we treating what happened every
time you do this I get 500 messages of
the sad like I'm dying of cancer I don't
know it's like I it's not that I don't
have empathy but I I wish you guys could
see my inbox it's like an overwhelming
amount like why you all dying in the
audience listen to Brian Johnson I got
stop dying stop dying I get those emails
too Dan and and it is it's really
frankly depressing yes that's what I'm
saying and and not that it like
obviously the person I want to help all
of you we love you all has it way worse
I'm not trying to uh compare that but uh
just to give you a sense of scale it's
like we can't help everyone so it just
it feels unfair to just randomly do it
for some and not others and so yeah
funky Miss wimpy send me the invoice I'm
not making any guarantees just send it
okay now leave me
alone 5,000
dongar all right what kind of procedure
was it was an elective that's what I'm
you know what I mean are we talking did
you get an El Ive surg you know you get
your nose straightened what are we doing
and what have you done to not die and
exactly what's your diet like have you
been sleeping sleep you getting red
lasers red laser therap true these are
all send all that information funky so I
can gauge how deserving you
are um Hal JJ says please say happy
birthday to my little sister Ava we love
you Ava happy birthday bab nice happy
birthday this man is boo because of
incest there's really um says Caitlyn
con uh conflicting facts on the Blue
Man incest causes people to be blue
since when incest it needs to go
probably pretty far well in the in that
but they like the royal family used to
be inbred like Generations I never see
any blues it's a cover up they kind of
purple they're purple they're blue yeah
maybe somebody somebody asked I did say
this already but I'll say it again megi
says ELO will there be a TF sale at the
live show this year yes there will yes
big time Big
Time um it's a win-win we get to clear
some space we get to sell you guys stuff
for super cheap this one comes from abh3
podcast he says I want to get my mom a
TV for Christmas send that is that
a real donation or did you just fake it
that's a real donation thanks man all
right if you can put $5 on top of that
please send us the link what kind of TV
are we talking
I actually I actually gave my mom a TV
last year for Christmas but it was the
TV that my dad gave me and my brother to
keep at our house but we didn't need a
TV we secretly gave it to my mom cuz her
divorce you regifted I regifted was it
did you use it oh my God no I didn't use
it I had the intention to give it to my
mom but my dad was
pissed I didn't negotiate that in the
divorce settlement that's funny um uh
Avery Mega awesome nerd says Ethan
please pay off my student loans I have a
small uh uh donation of 218,000 please
thank you bro appreciate it gang gang oh
my
God thank you for the Dono Dasha she
donated $5 and said can I have
$5 somebody asked for 25 bucks for some
weed for weed yeah I mean that's as
good a reason as any to be honest s the
invoice this isn't real is ITP that's
the prince that's the king yeah that is
the yeah this is this is the uncolor
corrected version this is what incest
looks like do you see these fingers
that's the type of that you can
expect blue I mean what the what's
your argument family has a a rare
recessive gene that makes their skin
blue is what I'm saying what yeah
yep what else does it it's actually a
blood disorder that causes it usually
when there's stuff like that there also
is like other side effects of the
condition it what what is it called let
read about it uh it is
called
meog
globin
minia
yes nice I'll send you the
link Joyce says can I get some luck wish
upon me for my crochet Market this
weekend good luck we wish you all the
best out there crochet your heart out
girl tactical Noob Tube my mom wants a
yacht gimme gimme a yacht futing you're
asking for Millions now
man here is a uh here it
is let's learn about this I'm just
waiting for the sandwiches by the way I
see I mean the show is over it's
definitely over yeah meth meth methogo
Bima oh why is there a vial of oh is
this blood is this Blood chocolate brown
oh chocolate brown blood due to the meth
meina that's sick makes your
blood Brown it can't it can't bind to
oxygen which is what produces the the
red color so because it can't B it's
that bluish is that a problem isn't that
fatal yeah yeah how did how do they live
doesn't blood need to carry oxygen in it
uh I don't know I mean clearly that that
one guy was pretty old so I guess it's
manageable somehow your symptoms may
include headache dizziness shorten of
breath nausea poor muscle corination
blue colored skin oh there's a name for
it
cyanosis cyanosis now we're getting
closer to the blue skin thing
complications may include seizures and
heart arrhythmias hold on now we're
getting one level deeper because we
really care about the blue skin there
just click on the blue skin link right
next to it wait there was careful yeah
back on
Wikipedia oh
this is that what it was yeah okay I
guess it's a little blue oh yeah mhm
soos is a change of body tissue color to
a bluish purple Hue as a result of
decrease the amount of oxygen bound to
the
hemoglobin so maybe there there's still
some oxygen but just a reduced amount
right you only need 10 to 20% to see
signs of slightly uh blue skin oh wow
cyanosis is apparently usually in the
blood tissue covering the thin skin
including mucous membranes Lips nail
beds and earlobes
also the the genitals is that thin mucus
membrane I wonder this dick is probably
super blue for sure it is uh some
medications may cause discoloration such
as medications containing oh here it is
uh silver amod doron or silver
furthermore Mongolian spots large birth
marks and the consumption of food
products with blue or purple dye can
also result in the bluish skin tissue
Jesus how much blue dye are you
eating uh appropriate physical
examination and history taking is a
crucial part yada yada y okay we love we
love our our blue people don't we yeah
it's a good time blue they are the best
we love them we love them
all we love them love groups of blue men
I mean usually people that are blue are
dead so this is good this is there's
living blue people and we love that mhm
we love our living blue people they're
terrific tremendous people find people
on both sides the living and the dead
the Papa Smurf guy we're looking at I
saw unfortunately has passed so may oh
no rest in peace rip to the goat damn my
dude so if he dies then his must
get really blue for real mhm
yep blue all right I got I uh is there
any ETA on those Lena where the hell I
think she's grabbing right now okay
these deliveries are just so brutal I
mean we ordered that like three didn't
we it's because they're big orders
that's the only is it that big it's
there's like 12 people here yeah okay
but like it make take maybe it takes
five minut or 10 minutes instead of five
minutes to make the sandwich this is
big uh all right hell listen
guys have a terrific weekend I love yall
thanks for being here thank you to our
members you guys mean so much much this
is next week is our last week of shows
get we have a Friday show we do okay so
we're doing a full week and then a bonus
episode on Sunday night for everybody
wow and the show starts I believe at
7 well we'll talk about it more next
week uh yeah the show starts at uh 7
o'clock Pacific and also just a reminder
that down in the description and pinned
in the chat right now is the survey for
the steamies get your votes in there
people
it's your voice we want to hear Ian is
did it go
up he's checking right now go out and
vote people
vote if you don't vote you can't
complain that's what they say Rock the
vote people vot never mattered before
every vote matters stay dump I'm saying
their vote never mattered this much
before no uh We've gained about 30 or
we've gained about 5,000 votes this
episode close though we're at
35,000 last year was nuts yeah all right
we'll see maybe as as people watch this
episode yeah we'll get there we'll
regardless it's it's a statistically
significant amount of votes it's fine
it's true yeah all right thank you
everybody we'll see you next week we'll
be here three shows and then a special
live performance on Sunday for everybody
will be live broadcast on the channel
but we'll talk more about that uh uh
next week thank you guys love youall
thank you have a good
[Applause]
[Music]
weekend